these top 10 principles that I have put
together here for this program the first
of these principles came from a vedantic
scholar on the in the 10th Century his
name was tilopa and his first principle
says as talopa put it have a mind that
is open to everything and attached to
nothing one of the central principles of
my life is that no one knows enough to
be a pessimist about anything and that
each and every one of us when we close
our mind to what is possible for us or
what is possible for Humanity closes off
the genius that resides and lives in
each and every one of us having an open
mind doesn't necessarily mean finding
fault with all of the things that you've
been taught by other it means opening
yourself up to the potentiality and the
possibility that anything and everything
is possible so having a mind that is
open to everything and attached to
nothing really means finding within
ourselves the ability to get rid of a
trait that I find so common in the
Contemporary world do you know that most
people that I meet spend their lives
looking for occasions to be offended
they actually are out there hoping that
they can find some reason to be offended
and there's no shortage of reasons
they're out there everywhere the way
this person dressed the what the worst
person said they turn on their TV they
hear the news they're offended by this
someone used language that they didn't
like someone doesn't share the same
Customs at you and all day long in fact
if you keep track tomorrow you will find
probably a hundred reasons that you can
go around being offended but a mind that
is open to everything and attached to
nothing is a mind that says I'm never
looking for anything to be offended by
and that whatever anybody else out there
has to say my response to that is that's
an interesting point of view I've never
considered that before hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quitted my business
partner and the thing that kept me going
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen into their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Wayne
Dyer enjoy
I remember being interviewed for a
morning television show
and the woman that was interviewing me
said how does it feel to be talking to
audiences where people have all of these
strange beliefs
these weird things that they come to and
it it it intrigues me because one of the
uh one of the things that uh
that Emerson said
is in one of his very first essays he
says the first thing we have to say
respecting what are called new views
here in New England where we are right
now
is that they are not new
but the very oldest of thoughts cast
into the mold of these new times
that was in 1842 he was speaking about
that and this woman asked me the
question she said
doesn't it offend you that there's out
there's people out there and they're
talking about people using crystals to
heal somebody
and I remember my response
my response was that if I've got
hemorrhoids
and somebody out there is convincing me
that crystals are going to heal them I'm
ordering Crystal chairs I'm uh
why not
I mean all you have to do is understand
something called a placebo and what is a
placebo it's nothing more than a
convincing belief if I hand you this
pill and say this pill is going to cure
your arthritis and you take it and the
pill is just a sugar pill but your
arthritis disappears I'm into buying
those placebos where can I get some of
those placebos and it's true of
everything and it's when you think about
all the things that we enjoy and what
our life is like
um
it took people who had a mind that
wasn't closed to allow us to make the
progress that we've made progress is
impo is impossible
if you always do things the way you've
always done things but the other word in
this what talopa said is
be attached nowhere
be attached Noah attachment really means
I am deluding myself into a belief that
if I can't have or if I can't do this or
that thing then somehow I'm going to
become immobilized so an open mind that
is detached in one of uh in my most
recent book in a spiritual solution to
every problem I have a an observation
and it's an observation from Anthony
Demello a man I respect enormously a
priest
who um
in the way to love puts it this way
here's a great test for your
relationships
especially the relationships that you're
in uh with those whom you love not your
children but your spouses and your
lovers and and so on try this test on
for size
one
I am not really attached to you at all
I am merely deluding myself into the
belief that without you
I will not be happy
and two and here's the toughest test for
non-attachment
I leave you free to be yourself to think
your thoughts
indulge your tastes follow your
inclinations
behave in ways that you decide
are to your liking
how's that for a challenge
and so what most of us do in our
relationships and why they are not as
successful as we would like them to be
is that we become attached and we tell
ourselves that this person behaves in a
way that I find offensive then I can't
be happy I make my happiness my
fulfillment dependent upon those people
that I love being what I think that they
should be
and Detachment doesn't mean being a
victim it just simply means I know that
I can make my life fulfilled and happy
by having a mind that is open to
everything
and attached nowhere
the second principle
is a very simple principle
it says you can't give away
what you don't have
now it sounds ridiculous okay but it's
more than what meets the ear as you hear
this you can't give away what you don't
have
people who are not good at giving away
love
can't give away love because they don't
have it to give away if I want to give
you a dozen oranges
I can't give you those dozen oranges
unless I go out and pick up 12 oranges
someplace
otherwise all it is is just empty
rhetoric
and the same thing is true of virtually
everything in your life
you can't give away love for others if
you don't have love in here to give away
if what you have in here is contempt if
what you have in here is anger if you
have in here is fear then these are the
things you're going to be giving away in
your life
and I've often thought and I really
believe very strongly that there's a law
sort of a law in the universe I call it
the law of attraction
and the law of attraction is one that
works like this
you get back from the universe from the
world what it is that you put out there
in the world
and if you're putting out there into the
world that I am not worthy of attracting
Something Beautiful into my life that
the universe will respond back to you
with exactly that message
and there are people who come to me and
who came to me for years when I had my
own counseling practice and so on and
they would say to me
um I just keep attracting the same kind
of people the same kind of events the
same kind of uh losers into my life why
is that why do I keep doing it and I
keep attracting uh an absence of uh of
abundance I just can't seem to attract
abundance into my life I'm always behind
the eight ball I'm never getting ahead
and I suggested them I said did it ever
occur to you that that's the very kind
of message you're sending out to the
world and out to the universe that the
ocean of abundance is there and you can
go to that ocean of abundance
and you can take a Mack truck
and you can fill it up 20 times a day
and take it out of there and guess what
it doesn't impact at all the ocean of
abundance it doesn't even go down a
zillionth of an inch it's unlimited or
you can go to the same ocean of
abundance with a eyedropper
and you can just take this much out once
a month and say that's all that seems to
be available for me
and the interesting thing for me is that
when people go to this ocean of
abundance this uh unlimited World all
that I have is thine it says in the Holy
books all that I have is thine it's all
there for you but if you believe inside
that it's limited that you can only get
so much that other people are going to
get it before you do then you'll find
yourself
creating that very same thing and the
even more interesting part about this
you can't give away what you don't have
principle
is that if your message to the universe
is gimme gimme gimme which is a lot of
people's message to the universe I want
this from you I want that from you
please give me this I have to have that
that's what their prayer is like that's
what their messages you know and they
say I want this from the universe give
me give me give me
the universe's response back to that
kind of a mentality is exactly the same
the universe will say right back to you
over and over again give me
hear me hear me and you'll find yourself
never ever arriving but always being in
a state of striving always feeling as if
you're being neglected never feeling as
if you have enough always feeling as if
you're being shortchanged because you're
constantly under the pressure to give to
get back what the universe is demanding
from you and the interesting thing about
all of this the the irony of this is
that if you shift that
and you say
to the universe to the world
how may I serve
how may I serve
the universe's response back to you is
how may I serve you
how may I serve you and it's very
intriguing when you take your energy and
your attention off of what you are
demanding from the world and instead
saying what can I give to the world
and it's really the the basis behind
that very famous line of the President
John Kennedy's inaugural address ask not
what your country can ask what you can
do for your country and the irony of
that is and I've learned that in my own
life that when I stop thinking about
what was in it for Wayne Dyer and how
much could I get and I began to shift
and say how can I help you how can I
give to you what can I do for you and
people who write to me I send them
something
when when I encounter somebody that
needs help of some kind I'm very often
just giving that to them and then I find
that it just keeps coming back into my
life and once I shifted that energy off
of what can I have
into what can I give it seemed to me
that the Universe responded back with
the very same message what can I give to
you and the most incredible and
wonderful and beautiful abundance has
flowed into my life in every way that I
can possibly think of you can't give
away what you don't have
so take a look at an inventory of what
you do have
how much do you love yourself
how much kindness do you have in you how
much peace do you have in you how much
joy do you have in you and if you're
able to give that away as many times as
you can in a given day watch and see how
much more of that continues to show up
and come back in your life okay
the third principle is one of my very
favors
it's called there are no Justified
resentments
and this is a very difficult principle
for many people to get but one that I
believe very strongly in
I was in a group one time
of uh drug addicts and alcoholics
and I was one of the people that was a
sponsor and leading this group
and the sign on the wall said there are
no Justified resentments in this group
and
what I said to that group that that
night was no matter what anybody says to
you here no matter what kind of uh anger
comes directed towards you no matter how
much hate you may encounter showing up
in your life there are no Justified
resentments meaning that if you carry
around resentment inside of you about
anything or about anyone and I'm talking
about the person that you lent money to
and hasn't paid you back I'm talking
about the person in your life that you
feel was abusive in your life I'm
talking about the person who walked out
on you and left you for somebody else
I'm talking about all of the things that
you have justified in your heart and in
your life that you have the right to be
resentful about and I'm suggesting to
you that those resentments will always
end up
harming you and creating in you a sense
of Despair I've often said that
you no one ever dies from a snake bite
snake bite will never kill you you
cannot be unbitten once you're bitten
you're bitten
but it's the Venom
that continues
to pour through your system after the
bite
that will end up destroying you
so now you have to take a look at all of
the resentments that you may have in
your life
and I'd like to suggest to you
that I think
there is a wonderful metaphor for this
that I have created in my life
for how to make this work
and I think that Regis Philbin is the
one who's responsible for it all right
my buddy Regis
there's a show called Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire that has been popular all
over the world I'm in South Africa it
comes on all right I was in Australia
and they've got their own Australian
version
um and in Greece they have the Greek
edition of uh Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire and basically this show has
two levels that you have to get to
now the first level
is the one thousand dollar level
and at the one thousand dollar level you
basically have to answer a question like
on your hand you have some digits those
digits on your hand are called your feet
your nose your ears your fingers uh
and everybody whoever goes on the show
has this horrible dread that they're
going to go out on one of those
questions right so basically in order to
get to the thousand dollar level all you
have to do is answer five pretty simple
simple questions in order to uh to get
to the thousand dollar level now on this
program the thousand dollar level for
you in this metaphor
means that you will leave with something
if you get this at least get this
this is the thousand dollar level
you must send blame out of your life for
any conditions of your life blame has to
go
all right now blame means if you're
sitting there with a disease you say
without guilt it's mine I take
responsibility for it
this means that if you have been through
any tough circumstances in your life
this means if you have a minimal amount
of Financial Security in your life this
means if your children don't get along
with you this means that if your
neighbors are having taking up a
petition to get you out of the
neighborhood whatever it might be that's
going on in your life you name it and
everybody across the this great country
and across this world has a series of
these things that you're willing to say
I am here because of the choices that I
have made right now I'm willing to say
that even though it's difficult and we
know it's really not your fault we know
really there's a lot of people out there
who are really bad all right but
but you're willing to say no blame
that's the first level all right that's
where you understand no Justified
resentments and then and the uh Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire show there is
what is called the 32 000 level
and the 32 000 level is not only an
opportunity for you to walk away with a
sizable amount of goodies which you can
walk away from tonight in this program
but it also is the door opener to
multi-wealth but you got to get to this
in order to have an opportunity to move
into these Transcendent levels all right
millionaire spiritual uh status all
right you got to get through these next
five questions and this thirty two
thousand dollar question or level rather
comes to this
it came to me from a quotation
that I used in the writing of a
spiritual solution to every problem
I read the
a book that was written a couple of
thousand years ago by patanjali
the yoga sutras the aphorisms of
patanjali
and one of those sutures one of those
aphorisms observations that This
brilliant man made
almost 2 000 years ago
was this
he said if you become steadfast
in your abstentions of thoughts of harm
directed towards others
all living creatures
will cease to feel enmity in your
presence
now this translates to blame pretty
basic no more blame I'm just not going
to assign responsibility to other people
for where I am because now I have an
opportunity to get rid of it if I think
someone else caused it then I've got to
wait for somebody else to change in
order for me to get rid of it and you
might wait forever for that but if I
take responsibility for it I can do
something including move on which might
be the most important thing to do
but at the higher level when there are
no Justified resentments
what you are doing is what Saint Francis
did Francesco what you are doing is you
are at a place where you are sending
love in response to hate you are
literally saying no matter what comes my
way I am going to be steadfast in my
abstention of thoughts of harm directed
toward others I'm going to work hard at
no matter what comes my way having it
come out of me what I want to come out
of me and that is love and that is a
higher energy and if you can get to that
level
patanjali said all living creatures will
cease to feel enmity in your presence I
have a little girl a precious little
girl I have six precious girls and two
precious Sons but I have a a little girl
who is almost 12 and she loves animals
like no one I've ever met in my life I
mean her whole life revolves around
animals and when we walk in the woods
butterflies
avoid me
fly away from people around and they
come and they land right on her arm and
it happens all the time
all living Creed she couldn't have a
thought of harm directed towards any
living creature and patanjali said to us
all living creatures will cease to feel
fear or enmity or anger in the presence
of those who can send love in response
to the hate that's what I mean when I
say there are no Justified resentments
what I'd like to do I'd like to share a
little story here with you it's a very
tender story it was sent to me by
someone who sends me beautiful things in
the mail and I call it the teddy story
and I'd like to read this to you
if I can do it without tearing up
and this story illustrates this as well
as anything I've ever seen
there's a story many years ago of an
elementary school teacher her name was
Mrs Thompson
as she stood in front of her fifth grade
class on the very first day of school
she told the children a lie
like most teachers she looked at her
students and said that she loved them
all the same
but that was impossible because there in
the front row slumped in his seat
was a little boy named Teddy Stoddard
Mrs Thompson had watched Teddy the year
before and noticed that he didn't play
well with the other children
that his clothes were messy and that he
constantly needed a bath
Teddy could be unpleasant it got to the
point where Mrs Thompson would actually
take Delight
in marking his papers with a broad red
pen and making bold x's and then putting
a big F at the top of his papers
at the school where Mrs Thompson taught
she was required to review each child's
past records and she put teddies off
until last
however when she reviewed his file
she was in for a surprise
Teddy's first grade teacher wrote Teddy
is a bright child with a ready laugh he
does his work neatly and he has good
manners
he's a joy to be around
his second grade teacher wrote Teddy is
an excellent student well liked by his
classmates
but he's troubled because his mother has
a terminal illness and life at home must
be a struggle
his third grade teacher wrote his
mother's death has been hard on him he
tries to do his best
but his father doesn't show much
interest in his home life will soon
affect him if steps aren't taken
Teddy's fourth grade teacher wrote
Teddy's withdrawn and doesn't show up
much interest in school
he doesn't have many friends and
sometimes he even sleeps in class
by now Mrs Thompson realized the problem
and she was ashamed of herself she felt
even worse when her students brought her
Christmas presents wrapped in beautiful
ribbons and and bright paper except for
teddies
his present was clumsily wrapped in his
heavy brown paper that he got from the
grocery bag
Mrs Thompson took pains to open it in
the middle of the other presence
some of the children started to laugh
when she found a rhinestone bracelet
with some of the stones missing and a
bottle that was one quarter full of
perfume
but she stifled her children's laughter
when she exclaimed how pretty the
bracelet was putting it on and dabbing
some of the perfume on her wrist
Teddy Stoddard stayed after school that
day just long enough to say Mrs Thompson
today you smell just like my mom used to
after the children left she cried for at
least an hour
on the very day
she quit teaching Reading Writing and
arithmetic
and instead
she began to teach children
Mrs Thompson paid particular attention
to Teddy as she worked with him and his
mind seemed to come alive the more she
encouraged him the faster he responded
by the end of the year Teddy had become
one of the smartest children in the
class and despite her lie became one of
her teachers pets a year later she found
a note under the door from Teddy telling
her that she was still the best teacher
he ever had in his whole life
six years went by before she got another
note from Teddy
he then wrote that he had finished High
School third in his class
and she was still the best teacher he
ever had in his whole life
four years after that she got another
letter saying that while things had been
tough at times he stayed in school and
stuck with it
and would soon graduate from college
with the highest of honors
he assured Mrs Thompson that she was
still
the very best and favored teacher he
ever had in his whole life
then four more years passed and yet
another letter came this time he
explained that after he got his
bachelor's degree he decided to go a
little further the letter explained that
she was still the best and favorite
teacher he ever had but now his name was
a little longer the letter was signed
Theodore F Stoddard MD
but the story doesn't end there
you see there was yet another letter
that spring
Teddy said he'd met this girl and was
going to be married
he explained that his father had died a
couple of years ago and he was wondering
if Mrs Thompson might agree to sit in
the place at the wedding that was
usually reserved for the mother of the
groom
of course Mrs Thompson did and guess
what
she wore that bracelet the one with the
several rhinestones missing and she made
sure she was wearing the perfume that
Teddy remembered his mother wearing on
their last Christmas together
they hugged each other and Dr Stoddard
whispered in Mrs Thompson's ear thank
you so much for making me feel important
and showing me that I could make a
difference
Mrs Thompson came
with tears in her eyes and whispered
back Teddy you have it all wrong
you were the one who taught me
that I could make a difference
I didn't know how to teach until I met
you
isn't that a beautiful story
yeah
[Applause]
that symbolizes there are no Justified
resentments
work at reaching that 32 000 level
the place where
the only thing you have to send is love
because that's what's inside and that's
the message of our greatest spiritual
teachers
that's all they ever had to give away
the next principle I call don't die with
your music Still In You
and who better to quote than Thoreau
right here in Concord
when he talked about some of us hear a
different drama
and we must March to the music that we
hear
but all of you everybody watching
everybody here in this beautiful Parish
all of you have some music playing
and all of you have a heroic mission
there's no accidents in this universe
we all show up here
with a purpose
there's an intelligence that is a part
of everything and everyone and all of us
are connected to it
and
and too many of us
are afraid
to listen to that music and March to it
you out there
I know you have a book you wanted to
write
I know there's a composition you wanted
to compose I know there's a song you
want to sing someplace
maybe you want to raise horses out in
Montana
or maybe you want to open up an ice
cream shop on Cape Cod who knows what it
may be maybe you just want to travel and
see the world
maybe you want to go into a relationship
with someone but you've been afraid to
but your heart says it's the right thing
to do
all of us feel something
and in Leo tolstoy's famous novel The
Death of Ivan Ilitch
he asked this question
that would be terrifying to me
he says as he has his accountant from
Moscow lying on his deathbed
contemplating the horror of this
question
what if my whole life
has been wrong
I've known what my music is
playing right now
because I stand here in front of you
with these cameras and in this place
and as I sit down and write my books and
tell the world what I know are my truths
I feel always completely on purpose and
fulfilled and no time will I ever come
to the end of my life and say what if my
whole life has been wrong
whoever you are whatever that music is
however distant it may sound however
strange however weird Others May
interpret it to be
don't get to the end of your life
and know that you're going to leave
and not have it played yet
don't die with your music Still In You
it's the message of the greatest
teachers who've ever walked Among Us
it's the message I give to you today as
one of the principles for success and
peace in your life
the next principle
I call embracing silence
and embracing silence is not that I say
this to you because it's so important to
be quiet
what I have learned I have a dear friend
and many of you know we've put out tapes
together we've appeared on stages all
over the world together he's like a
brother to me his name is Dr Deepak
Chopra
a medical doctor
and a dear and close friend and whenever
anything is going on in my family
if I'm having a problem with one of my
children or with my in my own life and
if I call him up and I'll say Deepak or
his wife Rita I'll say Deepak what do
you think I should do he always has the
same answer meditate
[Music]
I'll say yes Deepak I understand
meditate but I said what do you think he
said Wayne go deep inside and meditate
always meditate I'll say will you put
Rita on when I meditate yes they are
and you know I've learned a lot in
meditation but what I know most about
getting quiet and getting peaceful is
this
that there's only one power in the
universe and it doesn't matter what you
call it you can call it Soul Spirit
Consciousness God you can call it Louise
you can call it anything that you want
but as Alan Watts said you can't get wet
from the word water it's not what we
call something that gives its substance
and this one power this one force that
flows through everything and allows
everything to be is indivisible you
can't cut it in half you can't divide it
it's one it's knowing the one and
everything in your life
is almost always given a division
male female
young oh tall short black white
good bad up down these are all
dichotomies these are all these splits
that we all have in our lives the whole
physical world that we live in and are
immersed in it's always immersed in this
Division I used to teach course at St
John's University in New York and I used
to tell my students when I was trying to
teach this principle anybody who can
come to class and bring with them a
magnet
that only has a North Pole
I'll give you an A in the course you
don't ever have to attend another class
and no matter how thin they would slice
that magnet there was always the South
Pole because the physical world is made
up of dichotomies but we have to learn
to fuse the dichotomies and infusing the
dichotomy dichotomies and blending the
want
that's what silence does for us
that's why embracing silence is so
powerful because no matter how many
times you cut silence in half it's like
zero you still only get silence
and then they say it's the it's The
Space Between the Bars
that holds the Tiger
and it's the silence
between the notes
that makes the music
these words that are coming out of my
mouth right now come out of the silence
and finding that silence and embracing
it means that you go to the place within
you that you cannot divide
just like you can't divide the source
the one the spirit you can't divide that
either it's only one
so when you go into your silence and you
begin to practice meditation
and you begin to make this a part of
your life and embrace silence
what you discover is this is where
you'll come to know your Source you'll
make conscious contact with yourself I
can't tell you how many people that have
come to me who have suffered from
serious illnesses who've been giving
given diagnosis that it's terminal and
that you can't do it who have gone out
to the wilderness and have decided that
I am going to commune with nature and
the transcendentalists Perot and Emerson
they believed that nature was our source
and that we were all products of Nature
and if you can get back to your Source
if you can get back to that feeling of
being with spirit that that's where
healing can take place
and I've had wonderful stories of people
who've told me that it was when I began
to embrace that silence
but I began to feel more connected
to my source Embrace silence because
it's a way to come to know God to know
your source
both are indivisible and the only
experience you can have
in your daily life
that even comes close to a spiritual
awakening
is silence
the next principle I call
giving up your personal history
[Music]
and I learned it from a man named Carlos
Castaneda who once said that one day he
said I finally realized that I no longer
needed a personal history
and just like drinking he said I gave it
up and that and only that has made all
the difference in the world
you know the nice thing about giving up
your personal history
is that if you don't have a story
you don't have to live up to it
all of us have these bags
a manure that we carry around with us
called our past and the people who have
done things to us and the events and the
circumstances all of this stuff that we
use and we bond to and we Bond ourselves
to these wounds of our past and we
identify ourselves on the basis of these
wounds and every once in a while we set
it down and we reach in there and we
smear it all over ourselves and then we
wonder why does my life smell so bad I
don't understand this
when in fact the now this moment merging
yourself into the now means that you may
have been in a relationship I had a
woman from Holland who came over to see
me whose husband had left her after 25
years she had four children and she just
had been on the verge of suicide and she
was losing weight and she was depressed
and she was taking all kinds of drugs
for it and she was getting sicker and
sicker because she just couldn't get
over it and she came to a book signing
that I was doing at a bookstore down in
Florida
and she said you've got to say something
to me you've got to say something to me
that will help me to get over this
and I told her this line I said
give up your personal history
merge yourself here now into this moment
and those 25 years are something if you
want to understand how to do it think of
your past
as
oh this hat
and this is your past now you can't just
set this thing down over here and walk
away from it and give up your personal
history because you'll always have it
there to look back at what you do is you
pick up your
past
and you embrace it
you understand it you accept it as I had
to go through these things that I had to
go through in order for me to get to
this place today and the evidence for
that is that I did you don't need any
more evidence you did and then you toss
it
you toss it you embrace it and you toss
it and you merge into the now
by giving up your attachment and some of
you have heard me use the metaphor of
the wake
Alan Watts talked about the wake is not
what drives the boat the wake is just a
trail that is Left Behind that's all it
is and so is the wake of your life
and the Wake doesn't make the boat go
and neither does the wake of your life
the reason why your life is going in the
direction that it is
the wake is a trail that is left behind
and it's an illusion to believe that it
is the cause of your suffering or your
struggles or your difficulty give it up
Let It Go embrace it understand it get
help doing that if you must
and then move into the now
the next principle I call
it's from a line of Albert Einstein he
said you can't solve a problem
with the same mind
that created it
in order to work at solving these things
called problems in your life you have to
change your mind it is your mind where
they live it is your mind that created
them they there is where you experience
them they're all Illusions you must
change your mind literally rewrite your
agreement with reality
one of the things I had said earlier is
that one of the most difficult things to
do in the world is to admit that you
were wrong admitting that you were wrong
is nothing more
than saying I have been making choices
with my mind that have created things in
my life that are not working
and I no longer intend to continue
making those choices
I was wrong
you don't have to make a declaration of
it you don't have to go out and feel
guilty about it you just simply say it
didn't work the relationship that I was
in before I behaved in these ways I
didn't realize that it wasn't working
for me now I do and this is where I
choose to be now
The Secret of a successful relationship
is to me
understanding that you put your
attention and your energy in a person
on what you love rather than what you
don't love Robert Frost said it so
beautifully we love the things we love
for what they are for what they are not
for what they ought to be not for what
they used to be but for what they are so
when you look into the eyes of a person
you're in a relationship with whether
it's your children you catch them doing
things right as much as you possibly can
that's often Tim takes a lot of hunting
but you'll find it
and when you think that my relationship
isn't working remember it's in my mind
what am I thinking about that person
and if I could just change my mind
and put my thoughts on what I love about
this person and keep them there that
makes the relationship flourish and
there are people who go through their
entire relationship history with no
anger no hatred
no bitterness and Only Love
the next principle
is I call it treating yourself as if you
already were
what you would like to become
in other words you get out in front of
your life
and you see yourself as having already
what you know you'd like to have and
deserve to have my children know how to
do this perfectly I have a daughter who
wanted a prom dress and the prom dress
was way outside the budget that I
thought a prom dress should be uh well I
thought a prom dress shouldn't cost over
twenty dollars so I do have a problem
right but I opted to somewhere around
250 to I don't know how much whatever to
me it was still more than I paid for my
first house okay uh but anyway she
called and said Dad this is the only
prom dress I could this is the I've got
to wear this prom dress if I don't wear
this prom dress it's just on and on and
on with this uh wonderful you know I've
got a I saw a wonderful book about how
to raise teenage daughters the title of
it is get out of my life
but first drive me and Cheryl to the
mall all right that's a that's the
actual title it's a good book
and so I told Serena I said it's just
beyond the budget I've got a certain
amount of money that I'm willing to put
for it and she said but I've already
seen myself wearing it I've already
tried it on I have a picture of myself
in the dress in my living room and I've
already showed it to the guy who's
taking me to the prom I mean it was this
whole thing about and she already saw
herself in it I said well if you see
yourself in it then you're going to have
to also see yourself as earning the
difference between what I'm wanting to
pay
and she Drew up a contract she went on
to the computer and on the background of
the computer you know where they have
these little background things they put
on there was 500 pictures of the dress
all right
and she signed a contract and said I'll
babysit I'll do this I'll do that and I
will pay the difference and she did and
she wore the dress because she
understood that you treat yourself as if
you already are what you'd like to
become there's a genius in you you have
to treat yourself as if you already were
that genius there's something you're
completely capable of see yourself as
already there then you'll act upon those
thoughts because the ancestor to every
action said Emerson is a thought
the next principle is called treasuring
your divinity
treasuring your Divinity there's a
wonderful observation that I saw from
from Emerson in self-reliance
it's about trusting your Divinity
knowing that you are connected to your
Source knowing that you are a Divine
creation and that there are no accidents
he said a man should learn to detect and
watch that gleam of light
which flashes across his mind from
within
more than the luster of the firmament of
bards and Sages
yet he dismisses without notice his own
thought
because it's his own
in every work of Genius we recognize our
own rejected thoughts they come back to
us with a certain alienated Majesty
we often reject our thoughts and we see
the things that we think of as Grand and
as genius and we reject them because
they're our own
treasuring our Divinity instead of being
terrified of it knowing that I am always
connected to my source there is no way
that I cannot because it is in you and I
am in you and you are in me and you can
never be separated from it there is no
place that this source is not it grows
everybody's fingernails it beats
everybody's Hearts it digests
everybody's Foods it opens all the
flowers and you're always connected to
it
and finally
the last principle
I call
wisdom is avoiding all thoughts which
weaken you
you know every thought has an energy
just like everything else in the
universe and if you have a thought of
Shame
it will weaken your muscles and what is
your heart but a muscle
if you raise a child who believe in
shame and feel ashamed of themselves
every time they think that shameful
thought
they will be weakened and if you have a
thought of fear and if you have a
thought of stress and you have a thought
of Anguish and anxiety all of these
thoughts and many more
are the thoughts that will always weaken
you when you are having a thought that
you know is it disempowering you shifted
shift it to one that is empowering
rather than disempowering
and the thoughts that Empower our
thoughts of neutrality and willingness
and love and ultimately thoughts of
divinity
and when you see a troubled person
who is out there struggling
at the highest level of unity
Consciousness or God consciousness
spiritual consciousness you recognize
yourself
in all that you see
there but for the grace of God go I and
I am connected to that person
changing your thoughts
I appeared on the tonight's show many
years ago several times quite a few
times
and I remember coming home
from The Tonight Show and I was walking
along the beach and they had taped the
show the night before and I was out for
a walk and a woman who lived in uh
the Northeast
stopped me and she said didn't I see you
last night how could you be here I said
well I flew the red eye and I was
walking along and she said you know
we're moving down here
she said
what do the people like here what's it
like
and I said to her I said well what are
they like where you live she said well
she said I I live in a very big city and
she said they're very pushy
and people are not very kind and they
don't have time for you and she said
it's really not very pleasant she said
that's one of the reasons I'm leaving
there
I said well that's pretty much what
you're going to find here
that's basically what the people are
like here
on the way back on the same day someone
else who had seen me the night before on
The Tonight Show who had lived in the
Midwest
stopped me and ask me almost the same
question she said you live here I said
yes she said what my husband and I are
moving here and we're looking for a
school she said what are the people like
you what's it like here
I said what are they like in in Chicago
where you live she said oh she said it's
the Midwest she said people are very
friendly they're open they open their
homes to you they're very loving they're
very kind she said it's a wonderful
place she said I love that I'm going to
really miss that I said that's pretty
much
what you're going to find here
it's what you expect it's what you think
about that expands it's what Emerson
taught us the ancestor to every action
is a thought change your thoughts and
you change your world change your
expectations
and you change around what you begin to
manifest and see showing up in your life
you are the sum total of all the choices
that you've made up until now
and anything about yourself or your life
that you don't like or isn't working or
is immobilizing you is to be looked at
in terms of can I grow
rather than why did I do it or isn't
this wrong
see the two ways to motivate yourself
are deficiency motivation which says
where I am I don't like
I don't like what I've done I don't like
the fact that I can't do this well or I
can't do that well so I will list these
things in my own repertoire and then I
will be constantly trying to repair
those deficiencies always assuming that
I'm deficient that there's something
wrong with me and I'm trying to fix it
and when you do that you spend your
whole life doing that
and you never arrive because your life
becomes a series of trying to get
someplace else
and it is
if you follow that if you live that if
you behave that then what you what
happens to you is you become a person
who will always suffer from this disease
called more
you always have to have more because
whenever you are getting where you want
to go let's say you want a hundred
thousand dollars in the bank and you
work and you struggle and you deny
yourself and you do all of those things
and you finally finally you get there
and here you are you got a hundred
thousand dollars in the bank
all of this stuff over here is of course
to your life and that is all you know
that's what you know how to that's how
you are that is your being that is your
way of being so that when you do get
here what you will do is say this is not
enough
you must a No Limit person
is never operating from deficiency or
from lack in their life they're never
saying I don't have enough
you see you're never going to get enough
you already are everything
you're everything that you need think of
it for just a moment everything that you
need to have total Bliss Perfection of
your life
you already are you already have it
you came into this world with nothing
that's how you're going out
and the time that you have here what you
have is your uniqueness your specialness
and you don't need anything else now
think on this
if you don't know how to appreciate what
you have and where you are in your life
you don't need anything else
because if you do get something else
you won't know how to appreciate that
either you'll just want
more
or you'll want it to be different or you
want it to be the way it used to be or
you'll want someone else to be the way
you think they should be successful
people or No Limit people or
self-actualizing people or interdirected
people however you whatever labels that
have been put on them by great thinkers
and philosophers and therapists and
people that have looked at human beings
these kinds of people are people who
always have enough
there are some people if you invite them
over and you say um
you know I'd like you to uh
I'd like you to come over tonight and
I'd like you to stay over if you can
instead of having to drive back and
they'll say well can you say can you
stay and say well I don't know if I can
stay or not um
well you could sleep on the cot oh no no
I could never sleep on the cot I can't
sleep on cots
I got a sciatica don't you know and I
have I have back pain and cots no that's
out of the question I couldn't sleep
when I got and what about breakfast well
we don't have any food but um we have
some old grapefruit that are in the uh
in the refrigerator they have a few
spots on them oh no I could never eat
grapefruit in spots no thanks I can't
eat grapefruit spots I just couldn't do
that you know
uh and these are people who uh never
have enough they are are not able to be
flexible and to change and there are
other people if you say would you like
to sleep over we've got a place in the
sewer
hey that'd be great I can handle that
no problem I slept there before it's all
right okay all we have is grateful oh I
love grapefruit well we got we've got
spots on oh I really like grapefruit
spots those are terrific I'll I'll go
for those there are some people who can
handle anything not because their
circumstances are different you see your
circumstances have very little to do
with your fulfillment in life very
little
it's it's how you're approaching your
circumstances it's your attitude towards
your circumstances that make all the
difference in the world and taking what
you are and accepting it I gotta show
you this
I don't know if the camera can get this
this is a little uh advertisement that
was in the Detroit Free Press uh for uh
last September I was giving a speech at
the Unity Church of today in Detroit and
it says uh Dr Wayne Dyer will talk about
your inner child and how to deal
effectively with problems in all
relationships and it was a real nice ad
you can see that then on top of the ad
in the same paper
there's another ad
and the ad says face it
right on top of Maya
there's no hiding from hair loss
and they got a picture of a guy
well a box over his head
and they have a before and after guy
there and the after guy
looks like he's just found fulfillment
and it says you can't run and you can't
hide hair loss is a problem and unless
you take action it will continue
now
we've got to look at this uh
in terms of uh what I can do with this
and how I can handle it see my daughter
helped me with being bald
a long time ago she said dad you're not
really bald don't think of yourself that
way she said you're just about this much
taller than your hair that's all
just sort of a nice way to look at it
too I just sort of outgrew my hair sort
of transcended my hair if you will all
right
No Limit people are human beings who
take what they are and accept it
and don't tell themselves that somehow
they're deficient because of anything
about themselves
this is a very crucial
uh concept for for me and for virtually
all of us it's this idea of taking your
life in your own hands and being the
kind of person that you choose to be and
understanding that everything that comes
your way
is an opportunity
is a blessing
and it wasn't until
I learned how to celebrate virtually
everything that came my way
that I was able to transcend it you see
everything that was given to us by God
whatever that is
is perfect
no one can deny the mountains are
perfect and the rivers are perfect and
the birds are perfect and the
hippopotamuses are perfect and and and
so on this is just what was given to us
everything else
that you have
on our planet that we have on our planet
comes about as a result of
thinking
thinking thought makes it so all right
this microphone comes about as a result
of thinking somebody imagines it
somebody then tells somebody else and it
and it creates it the dress that you're
wearing this shirt that I'm the shoes
that you have the stage these cameras
everything that you see that wasn't
given to us was created by man as a
result of the way that we think the way
that we think
so what gets inside of us as a cell
comes about as a result of the way that
we choose to think in our lives very
important principle to understand
because once you get a hold of thinking
and that it creates everything that you
have in your life
you can change and make it is absolutely
perfect as you want it to be because
thought makes it so
creative visualization is what we're
talking about here you the
imagery or the image that you have of
anything in your life is really like
mental Behavior it's like going out and
practicing if you go out and practice
with a basketball shooting uh free
throws over and over again that's
physical practice imagery is mental
practice it's mental behavior when you
have an image that you can succeed at
something when you have an image that
you can do it rather than that you can't
do it when you get into your car and you
have an image that you're going to find
a parking place rather than that
there'll be no place to park so you're
not looking for no place to park you
will start acting on the image that you
have very much like you will start
acting on the practice that you have
when you're shooting baskets or when
you're hitting a forehand or or working
on your soup or anything else that
you're doing
Bucky Fuller who I served with on the
hunger project advisory Council for nine
years who died not too long ago
said that 99 percent
of who you are you can't touch you can't
see you can't smell 99 of you
is Untouchable unsmellable invisible
it is what kankai's has called your your
conscious awareness
it's your it's what looks out behind
those eyeballs what is that it isn't it
isn't cells it's some kind of conscious
awareness that you are and make no
mistake about it you've occupied a whole
lot of bodies already
now this is not reincarnation talk
although I don't know about this
reincarnation people ask me if I believe
in it I said well
I taught in a junior high school in the
inner city of Detroit for four years
and I saw those dead bodies come to life
every day at three o'clock
so I believe
in reincarnation all right
now if what you if 99 of who you are you
can't touch and you can't feel and you
can't smell
then where did it what is it who is it
where are you what is this thing called
your essence or who you are and where
does it go now think of this you were in
a body I have a little baby girl who's
11 months old and she and we were all in
a body that size well it's only a body
about this big got fingers only this
long you know got a tiny tiny little
Parts all over the place I mean she's
only this tall
now is that her is that her essence
because I have other children who are
much older
and I am much older than that and I can
remember being three and being in a
different body still me still my Essence
they're different but totally different
doesn't even look anything like when I
was 11 months old and then I was 13 and
had a funny body at 13. but still my
Essence was there and a whole new body
hair is growing all over the place that
I didn't understand all kinds of things
happening to it you know then hair is
falling out of it later on you know
looking at those hairs that fall out and
say what held it in yesterday you know
what I don't know I don't even
understand that okay
and so it's like who I am has been in
many many bodies already
all right and that essence you see
everything on our planet
that is alive can never die but can
never die life doesn't die it just
transforms it just moves on to new
places and new ways of being new ways of
being and the way of being that is the
most Transcendent of all is this way
that comes from
seeing yourself as love and only having
that to give away only having that to
give away let's say I would have stand
up here in front of you and just
visualize for a moment that I have an
orange
and I take this orange and I squeeze it
as hard as I can squeeze it okay what's
going to come out
Jews what kind of juice
oh is it apple juice any chance
once in a while
come on now and then little mango juice
come out of an orange once in a while no
mistakes right never no matter what next
question everybody passes these are easy
okay why when you squeeze an orange as
hard as you can squeeze it does orange
juice come out
because that's not because it's an
orange because that's what's inside
isn't it on our planet when you squeeze
something
what comes out of it is what's inside
not too difficult all right
does it matter
if
your mother squeezes the orange
does it matter what instrument she uses
does it matter if you just had your
period and then you squeeze an orange
doesn't matter if your boss squeezes it
how about if your kids do it your kids
squeezing does it matter does it matter
what time of day suppose they do it at
noon all right how about at four in the
morning does that matter
whenever you squeeze an orange the only
thing you get out is what's inside right
no arguments
same thing works for you
same principle works for you it's a
principle of the universe all right
someone squeezes you
that is someone puts pressure on you
someone says things about you that you
don't like someone puts uh
uh attention on you whatever your boss
says something to you that you don't
like and out of you
comes anger
and out of you comes hatred
and out of you comes fear or out of you
comes stress or out of you comes tension
why
is it because of your boss and the way
they squeeze you never is it because of
your mother
I mean she really can be a pain
sometimes right is it because of your
children no what comes out of you always
when someone squeezes you is what's
inside this is the the vital principle
of being a No Limit person it's so
crucial to get this and understand that
that if you have any hatred in your
heart for anyone in this world or any
anger or any fear or any of those things
it has nothing to do with the rest of
the world it only has to do with what
you put inside now how does what gets
inside of you get there
that's the key how does it get there
as you think only as you think you see
there's no anger in the world there's no
stress in the world there's no tension
it's perfect we've already established
it's perfect place it works just fine
it's all flowing the way it's supposed
to flow
the evidence for it is it is
that's all the evidence you need just
look around you everything out there is
a miracle everything including you there
are no mistakes it's all perfect and
everything that happens to you in your
life
whether it's a trauma whether it's a
disease whether it's somebody treating
you in a certain way there's a lesson in
all of it no limit people understand the
lesson in life and therefore celebrate
the lessons
it's true and when you get to that point
in your life where you're not cursing
the things that come your way and
blaming the things that come your way
and particularly blaming it on somebody
else
and you hear it all the time
she hurt my feelings
how's that possible how can anybody hurt
your feelings your feelings come from
your thoughts no one can hurt your
feelings without your consent no one can
make a fool of you without your consent
no one can embarrass you without your
consent these are choices that you have
that come from the way that you think
someone calls you a name
hey stupid
and you turn around
I didn't even tell anybody I was coming
how did they know that huh
person who called you a name instead of
saying that's just their opinion that's
just where they are that's where they
are on the path and it's okay all of you
are in relationships right everybody has
a relationship of some kind or another
in your relationship
you have any problems
any of you have relationship you don't
have any problems
I'd like you to take this microphone I
want to sit down and listen to you
everybody in a relationship has problems
don't they right now when you say I'm in
a relationship
I got problems
therefore
there's something wrong
something's really wrong all right
now
if you're in a relationship and you have
problems and something is wrong you got
to call in a consultant right you got to
call in somebody to help you with the
problems you don't want the problems to
go on who are you going to call in
you only got yourself it's all you got
you might get a therapist once in a
while but they got worse problems than
you do
the only consultant who can help you
with your problems is you and who is
that consultant that you're calling in
we've already established that there's
something wrong with that person right
something wrong
so now you're going to call in a
disabled person
to deal with your problems in your
relationship right now this is a really
sick approach to curing your problems
you got somebody who says we got a
problem you don't talk to me I didn't
talk to you and you came home with last
week and this week I called you and you
didn't call and I was supposed to call
you and then you didn't do it and how
can you do that now this is the
consultant you're calling excuse me will
you come in and help us
that's the person you got to deal with
your problems
all right now what you can do is you can
change all of that around
you can say I'm in a relationship we got
problems
there's nothing wrong with that
that's the way things are you know my
problem is that you are different than I
am
and you think differently than I do and
you behave differently than I do and you
smell different than I do and you have
all of these attitudes over here that I
don't have nothing wrong with that
that's the way it is when two people get
together in a relationship you don't
have two people becoming one if you do
that then what you end up with are two
half persons who wants a half a person
in a relationship you always are single
even if you're married and for you know
and involved in relationship through
you're still always single you're still
always you your unique special perfect
self that is not trying to love
but who is love
who lives love who is
being
love
the same as if you pray to God and say
God will you please help me with my
problems and want God to do it for you
never have you've got to be God not be
afraid to carry God around inside of you
if you want to get healed you have got
to understand that you're not going to
get healed
if you are asking someone else to heal
you and ask any doctor that you know any
surgeon particular who's taking somebody
into surgery and ask them which person
has a better chance of living a
surviving say serious surgery is it the
one who has a will to live or is it the
one who's just given up and the surgery
and the cases are exactly the same all
right but the person who has that will
which we can't Define you can't go out
and get a bucket full of Will and bring
it in there it's an attitude it's an
approach it's a belief all right that
you can do something and when you have
that belief about yourself then you know
you've got so much better opportunity to
be well in your life and a belief is
everything I don't know if you've ever
thought of that I watched a little girl
five years old learning how to swim and
she's holding on to the edge of the pool
and she wants to get over here to the
steps and it's just uh five feet or six
feet and she'll let go into hold on
again and she'll let go and she'll hold
on again and finally there comes a time
when she lets go and goes for it okay
you fall boss that you've seen this with
your children you've seen and what you
ask yourself is in the moment before
that when she was holding on
and then look at the moment afterwards
does she have any different skills let's
change yeah the skills are they
shouldn't have any new skills these are
learning skills in that second what she
has is a belief that she can do it and
when you believe it when you really just
believe that you can do it that's what
allows you to swim and when you think
about it now do you know how to swim
yeah so when you dive into the water you
don't think about that you just know
when you dive into the water you can
swim you don't have any necessary
swimming skills or anything like that or
when you get on a bicycle you get on you
know that you're gonna unless you
believe you can't because you've never
gone out there and tried it and worked
on it and done it told a story of a
patient of yours who had that very
problem who said she didn't know how to
ride a bicycle yeah Gail who came to me
many years ago and you know why she said
she couldn't ride a bicycle because her
mother wouldn't let her get on One Cop
Out yeah absolutely and she had these
beautiful big white teeth and her mother
had always told her you could fall and
break your teeth and I wouldn't want
that to happen to you so here she was
now in her 30s and uh telling me that
she couldn't ride a bike and she was in
therapy and um I said to her okay let's
go
she said go where are we going I said
well I've got a bicycle downstairs and
I'm going to show you how to ride a bike
I'm gonna have you teach yourself how to
do this and he said look I didn't come
here to pay you the kind of money that
I'm paying you to have you teach me how
to ride a bicycle I came here to find
out why I can't I said oh well you're
going to need another 30 seconds of
therapy easy Okay the reason you can't
is because you never got yourself on a
bicycle and until you do you never will
know how and you just believe that you
can't oh that's the end of that there's
no more to talk about that now what we
have to do is get you to get out there
and we went downstairs and I it was a
woman's bike and I've helped a lot of
people to teach themselves how to ride a
bike and what you do when you teach you
help someone to teach themselves how to
ride a bike because you don't teach
anybody how to ride a bike okay uh is
you let them do it all themselves you
let them hold it you let them balance it
you let them move with it you let them
put the pedal down and and move it
themselves and you stand back you say no
when you're ready you know and then
you're moving and you hold on for a
second then you put your foot back down
and you you practice it and practice and
practice that all yourself you know it
was just someone encouraging you and
before long in just a matter of minutes
when I tell you it was minutes and this
woman had never been on a bicycle before
she rode like two blocks on a bicycle
she couldn't believe that she she now
had a belief being to me
means seeing the greatness and the
uniqueness in you and never letting
anybody else convince you to the
contrary when people ask me come on
you're always talking about being up and
you're always positive and so on you
mean to tell me that you're always that
way this is I say yeah yeah I really am
and it isn't because I'm out there doing
something in an artificial way it's an
authentic response to my heaven having
gotten the junk out of me
and the junk is the way that I used to
think the way that I used to think think
for a moment if you can visualize right
here a clock
a big clock
and the hands on the clock go from 1 to
12.
the clock starts right out here with the
minute hand and it goes over towards the
three the hour hand
minute hand
and that's the time in your life when
you are moving away from yourself from
your true self that's the time when you
are trying to put other people down
trying to prove that you're bigger or
better than somebody else trying to make
yourself right all the time as opposed
to uh being with somebody else it's like
you're moving away and a lot of people
spend a lot of time moving away from
their true self because your true self
is this little child it's this beautiful
little child inside of you
that has only love and acceptance for
everything in the world and no dis-ease
no absence of ease
you move away towards the three and then
you move down here this way and you're
still moving away from yourself until
you hit the six
the six is the point in your life
symbolically metaphorically here
when you are the furthest away from
yourself that you can be it's the low
point in your life
it's the point where many people break
down or many people break down their
relationships or they they feel full of
Despair they feel full of hatred
whatever it may be and a lot of people
die then a lot of people are put into
hospitals then a lot of people have to
really seek out therapy then and so on
and when you're at that thing there's
another part of the clock that goes from
six to twelve that I think of as the
living in the light
and this is when and see this clock hand
never can go back it can't go back it
can only go this way it only goes this
way as does life it only goes this way
forward
in this period This Place between 6 and
12
that's when you start coming back to
yourself
that's when that's what enlightenment is
that's what that's the pathway to
Enlightenment when you send out that
stuff that is destroying you that is
killing you in one way or another
and you move yourself back over here and
eventually you get yourself all the way
back this is the light over here this is
the place where you can't go back
you'd be tempted you might be tempted to
steal you might be tempted to to to use
anger you might even slip a little bit
and you catch yourself
I can just not too long ago there was uh
we we got a problem with our sprinkler
at uh in my home one of the sprinkler
heads is off and if you ever seen that
happen you get a gusher going up there
and I've been wanting to get that thing
replaced for the longest time and I'm
walking out of the bank and there's a
sprinkler head right there in front of
the bank now I practically own this Bank
okay so I'm gonna go there every day and
I do a lot of business with this bank
and I'm looking at the sprinkler head
and I think you know all I have to do is
just unscrew this thing I wasn't
honorary they'll replace it tomorrow
morning it's it's 98 cents or whatever
so I actually get down there and I and I
start turning the sprinkler and then I
start thinking do I want this Karma you
know do I want the do I want to steal do
I want to take I know it's only a 99 and
if I went into the bank they'd probably
give me one anyway if I asked them and I
turn and I just turned it back and I
said if I want a sprinkler head I'll go
and buy one for myself this doesn't
belong to me it was just like a split
second of weakness there or whatever but
it Illustrated to me that I can't go
back there I could never and there was a
time in my life when I could have done
that I can be absolutely Frank with that
I could do that uh I can't go back there
anymore
that's where you start that's the place
to start because when you get all of
that out when that's all gone and I mean
gone and it only comes about as a result
of the way that you think so it's just
changing around your approach to life
the way that you think in life when that
starts to go away
what you've become filled up with is
what your natural self is which is this
loving accepting not fighting the
universe but instead living in it and
going with the flow and all of the kinds
of cliches that you've heard a thousand
times it is that's the metaphor there
and you see every time you try to go
back
can't do it you can't do it and the
ingredients
that make for a No Limit life
are five in my opinion
the first is quality rather than
appearances you begin to change your
thinking from
appearances
and how things look and how other people
view me
okay because every time you find
yourself upset in life about anything
that anyone else has said
what you're really saying is what you
think of me is more important than what
I think of me all right so you change
from appearances to what I call Quality
thinking quality what is the quality of
my life rather than how does it appear
to others now do you tell yourself that
because my friends don't like me
that that means there's something wrong
with me now that's see that's what you
have to learn that another person's
opinion is just that it's their opinion
and that's all it is
every time you are upset or your
children are upset because of what
somebody else says about them including
their peers what you are really saying
in that moment and this is really
important what you're saying is what you
think of me is more important than what
I think of myself and you must never
give anybody that kind of power and
control over you because they will
always have it
the funny part about approval
for those of you who really want it and
real now I'm here to tell you that I
like approval I enjoy it I find it one
of the most exciting things in the world
I like it when people read my books I
love it when people applaud I like it
when people uh tell me nice things and
all I like approval I'm the first one to
admit it what I don't do is I don't need
approval there's a big difference
between wanting approval and needing
approval when you need approval it means
you become immobilized when you don't
get it
from making other people's opinions more
important now for those of you who say
yeah but I want approval and I need it
and if I don't get it and so on then
understand this the people who get the
most approval in life
are the ones who care the least about it
and the ones who get the least approval
are the ones who are always going after
it so if you want approval in this
paradoxical way that I'm talking about
it
stop needing it stop concerning yourself
about ask yourself who gets the most
approval in life
think of the person that gets the most
approval and you'll see that that person
couldn't care less what other people are
thinking
they're so busy being they don't have
time to notice what their neighbors are
doing Thoreau said this he said if you
advance confidently
in the direction of your own dreams
and Endeavor to live the life
which you have imagined
you will meet with a success
unexpected in common hours
what that means is that success is not
something that you can get in life
success is an inner process
success is something that you bring to
everything you do in your life it isn't
something you get out of what you do
and when you get that and you learn how
to get the junk out and Advance
confidently doing what makes the most
amount of sense to you based on your
inner signals and the one issue of
morality which is you never interfere
with anybody else's right to do the same
each person has their own right to
advance confidently in the direction of
their own dreams
and when you violate that you're
violating the principle of the universe
the essence of the universe which is
cooperation and harmony
then success will begin to chase you and
it will come into your life and arrive
in your life in amounts that you never
dreamed of before
that you never dreamed of things will
start happening to you that you would
never imagined before
I'm working on a book right now that's
going to be called you'll see it when
you believe it
when you start believing
and some of these principles you'll
start seeing things that you were blind
to for so long when you were back here
in the two and the three and the four
and the five when you were moving away
from yourself as long as you're moving
back towards your Universal Essence your
harmony with yourself your cooperation
with the rest
things will start happening in ways that
you never dreamed up
Jung called it uh
synchronicity
and we it's a term that we use to to
explain how unexplainable coincidences
sort of happen in our life and how come
these things happen I'm going to share a
couple of those with you before we leave
the
the quality versus appearance in your
life means that you get that inner
candle flame working in a way that gives
you quality independent of what other
people think of you Maslow in defining
self-actualizing No Limit people said
they are independent of the good opinion
of other people
of the good opinion of other people
independent of it they're so busy
advancing confidently doing the things
that make sense and bringing success to
changing their baby's diaper and
bringing success to weeding their Garden
and bringing it to the job they bring it
on the airplane so that when they run
into somebody who is who is rude to them
a stewardess That is rude they don't see
it as an attack on them it's just where
they are and they send them love help
them a little bit you know they're kind
when somebody wants to get in on the
freeway
and their uh one old Temptation when
they were on the one to the sixth side
was to say oh yeah nobody's getting in
front of me I'm getting there first it's
like I slowed down a little bit they
don't have all that type A stuff of
having to beat somebody else and having
to defeat somebody it is it's a new way
of being it's a way of quality where
your Harmony allows you to cooperate and
you are a part of what this whole thing
is about
new way of being quality rather than
appearances another new way of being
very important living your life on
ethics rather than rules ethics rather
than rules all these rules all these
ways of having to do things somebody
else dictates to them do you know that
some of the most immoral acts in the
world have been perpetrated in the name
of the rules these are the laws what do
you think Nazi Germany was all about
everybody doing all these horrible
things to other people I'm only doing my
job was the defense we all heard at
Nuremberg I was just doing my job if
it's an immoral rule it's immoral to
obey it
and self-actualizing people as Maslow
tells us have rules inside of them that
they could never obey never disobey ever
and they have to do with ethics how you
treat people how do you think we get to
where we are now you know who Rosa Parks
was
the woman in the South the black woman
in the South who said not today I'm not
going to the back today no way I know
what the rules are the rules were all
over the place if you didn't need if you
needed a reminder there were signs every
place colored in the back white in the
front and she said no
I'm sitting here
and that made all a difference
ethics not rules
when your children start disobeying
rules that need to be disobeyed
don't be surprised when I was in the
service
they had a policy on Guam where I was
stationed which would not allow the
guamadian civilians to shop in the px's
and the Navy exchanges
but they did allow all other civilians
to shop in the Navy exchanges and px's
but if you were glomanian that is if
your skin was dark and your eyes were
shaped a little different then you
couldn't
a clear outright violation I was a
serviceman I was in the Navy I was a
Communications cryptographer
they had a newspaper on the Guam daily
news and it said an invitation to speak
your mind
[Music]
there was a letter writing contest
and they offered 75 dollars to the first
prize winner 75 this was 1961.
that was a fortune to me that was a
month's pay in the Navy at that time
almost
So I entered the contest and I knew I
would win it I had already written a
novel at that time a whole novel I'd
written while I was on Guam
I knew it wasn't going to be a contest I
felt sorry for the other people entering
it I knew I was going to win this
unfortunately I didn't realize that when
you're in the service
and you have an opinion and you don't
submit it to the chain of command
that you can be court-martialed for that
so the headlines on next week's Guam
Daily News where U.S sailor a sales
policy of discrimination
big hot stuff all right
and I was called before a vice admiral
Commander Naval forces Marianas Islands
and threatened with a court martial
because I had disobeyed the rules
even though the rule was immoral there
are lots of them like that
and when I went in and they threatened
me with the court martial
I told him
this was my battle plan
they didn't have Xerox machines in those
days so I had to get a lot of carbon
paper
I wrote a letter to the president John F
Kennedy
and I wrote a letter to the Secretary of
the Navy
and I wrote a letter I was my hometown
was Detroit I wrote a letter to the
Detroit news and a letter to the Detroit
Free Press
telling them what was happening to me as
a result of just expressing my opinion
about an immoral act that was going on
over here on Guam
and I showed the naval uh
vice admiral my letters right there I
said I've only sent the one to the
president and the secretary of the Navy
these letters go to the newspapers
across the country there's one there to
the New York Times as well in the Los
Angeles time it was uh and I just spread
them out before him I said if you Court
martial me
punish me in any way for this
then what's going to happen is the world
is going to find out about this policy
and I'm prepared I'm ready I can handle
it and I was 20 years old at the time or
21.
not only did I get a blessing from that
because all things come in blessings for
you
I got out 90 days early
and they stamped on my record
Pi because the president took it up and
sent it to the secretary must have
and I never heard from him but I uh the
pi on your record means political
influence
and they don't like anybody with
political influence in the military and
as soon as they saw that they said this
is somebody we probably will be uh
giving a discharge real soon there was
no there was no court martial and in
September of 1962 a brand new policy was
initiated on Guam which allowed any
civilian to shop in the Navy exchanges
and it came about
as a result of someone saying these
rules are immoral and therefore it's
immoral to obey them new ways of being
ethics rather than rules and when your
kids want to know why how come these
rules are so stupid how come we have to
do this encourage them to change them my
mother always did that she would have to
help me get out of the out of the messes
that I got myself into because I I did
it in my impetuous youth I would just
when they would say to me what's more
important your job or school I was just
honest I said to my job of course that's
how I felt in those days
but what you do put out in the world is
exactly what's coming back to you and if
you find things coming back to you that
you don't like and don't understand
don't ask yourself why these things are
coming to you
ask yourself what you're doing to make
them come back to you
and when you start putting the
responsibility on yourself you'll start
seeing dramatic changes dramatic changes
a new way of being
instead of Ethics instead of rules
ethics
a new another new way of being instead
of
looking all your life for achievements
and externals
try living your life on knowledge for
the sake of knowledge knowledge instead
of achievement
for the sake of knowledge being in a in
a context in which
you don't have to collect a lot of merit
badges you don't have to collect a lot
of a lot of awards and other people's uh
value judgments that you go to school or
you go out into the world or you read or
whatever it is you do because it makes
sense to you not because of what
somebody else
is going to put on a transcript or where
you're going to appear in a class list
we need to help our children to
understand and value
the importance of knowledge for the sake
of knowledge
and doing things that make sense rather
than taking the easy way
knowledge rather than always trying to
achieve we're in an achievement-oriented
society which tells us that we evaluate
and judge a human being based upon how
many achievements he has but most of the
people who get caught up in that trap
and are always in this circle of trying
to get ahead trying to always get ahead
their reward for that almost always is
higher blood pressure
ulcers early deaths and even things like
cancer we're beginning to find out are
related to
kinds of stresses that we have and
remember it's a perfect Universe there's
no stress in it
there's only people thinking stressful
thoughts
and when you put that pressure on
yourself to always achieve and get ahead
of the other guy you miss what it's
really all about there's nothing wrong
with goals
it's falling in love with them that's
the problem it's not being able to be
flexible and be alter them if you have a
goal to get here to get a hundred
thousand dollars in the bank to get to
this promotion to get two cars in your
garage whatever it is that your goal is
and you're on your way to that and
you're always working at the goal all of
this stuff on your way to the goal is
called striving and that's what you
learn striving striving is a very low
level place to be when you get to your
goal because all you've ever known is
striving you will just always suffer
from this disease called more you will
just upgrade your goal to two hundred
thousand dollars for cars and two houses
and another wife and a younger one and
and all of these kinds of things if you
have a goal and you understand that
every step along the way is the present
moment to enjoy and to live then the
goal won't become any Obsession I don't
have any goals in my life people ask me
where are you going to be five years
from now what are you going to be doing
what's next for you I just uh I remember
what Lincoln said who to me was like the
greatest person who ever sat in that
white house
he said I've never had a policy he said
I just tried to do what made the
greatest amount of sense each and every
day of my life as I sat there as the
President of the United States
and I think there's something really
significant in that that you don't have
to get it all planned out and follow a
certain pattern and do it a certain way
if you just sort of trust your inner
instincts and go with that and live each
moment the goal stuff will all take care
of itself but if you're sacrificing and
pushing your life aside and and
suffering on your way to trying to get
someplace
you'll never get there it will always
elude you because once you get there
you'll just have to upgrade it and
that's because that's all you'll know
nowness is that purest form of Sanity
living in this moment and enjoying it
and all the rest of it will sort of work
its way out
another new way of being for me
is to think of yourself in terms of
personal Authority
rather than being an authoritarian
personal Authority
a person who has authority never needs
to dominate anyone else ever dominating
doesn't become necessary in business
you can have authority the people who
have the most Authority are the ones who
listen the most
and the ones who are the most
conscientious about what do other people
have to say a person in a relationship
who has to dominate somebody else and
has to make the other person submissive
shows that they don't have authority
because they're getting their power not
from within for themselves but on the
basis of who they can control and that
never lasts that never lasts the only
thing that lasts is having inner power
if you will know thyself that's what
Shakespeare said know thyself the more
you know yourself
the more you
the more you become honest with yourself
uh honesty becomes just a way of life no
I don't think the world necessarily does
but you can't run your world you can't
run your world based upon what the rest
of the people in the world want or don't
want to me honesty is like it's a Karma
that goes out into the world how people
treat you in the world is their karma
how you react is yours and what when you
react to it with dishonesty that's what
you're putting out into the world
dishonesty and when you put this honesty
out into the world that's what's going
to come back to you because what goes
out is what comes back that all as you
sow so shall you reap I mean it's it's
in every great uh institution that there
is in the world whether it's a religion
or a philosophy or whatever what you put
out is what comes back whatever you
plant is what you're going to get back
and the more that you put out honesty
just because it's what you are because
you are being honesty you're not trying
to be honest you're just being honesty
then that's what will come back to you
on a regular basis and when it doesn't
you'll just see that as another test for
you to pass
and finally
a fifth way of being
that is new
for me it has become a way of life
it's called
serenity
instead of acquisitions
the more you try to acquire
the more you try to get the more you try
to collect in your life and evaluate
yourself on the basis of that the less
Serenity you're going to have
more is less it's almost a secret of the
universe
Serenity means inner peace
means that you can find joy in every
moment that you have in your life
instead of always looking for it it
means that uh
while you are
driving along the countryside you know
and seeing uh instead of saying uh this
is I'm on my way to this point that you
can open your eyes and see it with new
eyes see see the rolling mountains see
the grass see the deer see the sky see
you can just stop wherever you are in
this second wherever you are and just
look around you and you can begin to
appreciate just your and your
surroundings and your environment then
you can begin to appreciate the people
that are in your life and even the ones
that are negative and and you're having
the most difficulty with you can
practice a new way of being with them
which is sending them love sending them
flowers send them books send them a tape
send them something and just see what
kind of reaction that you get super
emotional health is just an attitude an
attitude is everything
I want to
summarize these new ways of being and
give you the most important uh
ingredient on the path as we leave
I said that it's quality in your life to
be focusing on rather than appearances
and it's ethics rather than rules and
it's knowledge rather than achievement
all the time and it's being personally
an authority on yourself rather than
authoritarian and trying to be dominant
dominating someone else or to be
dominated and serenity which is the name
of my little girl my youngest daughter
Serena
um rather than
Acquisitions and accumulations and
trying to prove yourself that way and
when you get that Serenity which comes
from the way that you think always
then you will replace all of the other
junk that keeps you back here between
six and one on that clock and once you
pass it once you get past it you'll
never ever be able to go back because
the light living in the light is a way
of it's a way of being that if you're
not there you don't get it yet but once
you see it and once it begins to and
take over your life you can never go
back that that is your purpose it isn't
your purpose isn't to try to be loving
your purpose is to be loved and only
have that to give away well but there's
one other ingredient
and it's really crucial forgiveness
is the vital ingredient on the path
of enlightenment
and if you don't know how to do it
and practice sending out love take the
person or the people that you're having
conflict with any place in your life
send them something you don't have to
even do it physically
just send them something
that comes from inside
and what's inside is how you choose to
think and if you can make that love and
do that and that is to me the test
not whether you can love someone when
they smell good when they do everything
that you're supposed to but whether you
can love someone who has sent you hate
or anguish in your life and send it back
you don't have to forget you don't have
to go back
but you got to get it out of you because
it is blocking you and holding you back
and when I said you'll see it when you
believe it
all my life I had wanted to write
fiction a parable
three four years ago I decided to go off
to Hawaii to Maui to kanapali Beach and
to write now the books that had met the
most difference in my life were a little
prince
Candide
Siddhartha
Jonathan Livingston Seagull Illusions
Alice Through the Looking Glass
Gulliver's Travels
Parables teaching Parables stories
that can tell a message
I went over to Molly
and I sat down on the beach and I've
been talking about writing this I've
been talking about doing this and it was
something that
I have a little girl and her name is
Skye
SK y e
I decided to reverse the letters in her
name
e y k s
and put an i in there which symbolizes
the self icus
and I just created this parable of a
woman whose name is icus who lives on
another planet the planet is Uranus
and it's a duplicate mirror image of
Earth only icus can only see things as
they are now
we would like them to be and therefore
people are neurotic on Uranus because
they have to be she gives the anxiety
attack report if you will because
anxiety really does attack over there
and tells about anxiety coming in on the
weekends and so on well my visitor
in my Parable goes to Uranus mitikus she
cannot understand as he describes Earth
why people would be neurotic by choice
on Earth why would anybody be unhappy or
depressed or miserable when they don't
have when anxiety doesn't attack and
when elevators really don't scare you
and when if you want a complex on Uranus
you want to give a complex to your wife
you go to the store and buy one and she
says what happened well my husband gave
me a complex you know and it's true
whereas on Earth if you have a complex
it's because you've chosen to have one
so you can't figure it out okay so she
comes here observes our people and
begins to see the secrets of the
universe and gives us these secrets
talks to the top leaders in our field
and that was my Parable and I wrote it
and she gives all these wonderful
Secrets some of which I've been talking
about here today but what I want to tell
you is that my wife gave me a license
plate and the license plate says I kiss
okay it's a vanity play and I was
pumping gas on Federal Highway in Fort
Lauderdale Florida and a little man from
Greece came up to me
and he said but means this fias uh which
is how you say that in Greek and I said
well that's just a word it's my
daughter's name spelled backwards it's a
parable that I wrote he said no he said
in Greek that's a word
so what could that word be he said it
means best wishes for all
you'll see it
when you believe it the great big
erroneous Zone The Cosmic erroneous Zone
if you get this one you'll have it and
understand it all
there is no way
to happiness happiness
is the way we live in a
celebrity obsessed world only
look at me
notice me
the dial teaches something completely
the opposite
listen to the 66th verse of the Dao
water again the sea stays low and
because the sea stays low all of the
rivers and all of the streams empty into
it
because it stays humble because it stays
in that place of just allowing
everything to come to you he was trying
to teach us
the important lesson of letting what we
know is coming come to us
I practice this so much more now in my
life than I did at one time
I can remember years ago
I was uh I had written a book called
your aronia sounds back in the 70s and
um
and it stayed on the New York Times
bestseller list for something like 27
months
and
each many weeks it would be number one
and then it would go down to number
three and then it would go to them or
two and down to seven and all of that
and I was doing The Tonight Show in
those days on a regular basis and so
many of the other shows the Merv Griffin
and the Phil Donahue and Dinah Shore I
became like a regular on the diner show
I was like you know hobnobing with Bert
Lancaster folks and you know just the
and um
what you do is you call and find out
where you appear on the uh on the
bestseller list for the following week
on Wednesday so you call up on Wednesday
not for the Sunday coming up but for the
following week
and I called home and my ego was pretty
strong and I was very much into a lot of
notice me I I really believe that true
nobility is is not about being better
than anyone else now it's it's about
being better than you used to be and I
think I'm better than I used to be and
just about I mean I know that I'm better
than I used to be in every quality or
every characteristic that I hold to be
valuable
um but in those days I was
into notice me
and I called home and I had trained my
wife to call the New York Times she had
this special number that she could call
and with a certain code and she could
find out where I was going to appear on
the bestseller list the following week
so I called her up and I said
where am I on the best seller next next
week you know out in California doing
something and she said
you're not on the best seller list
I said what are you talking about I was
number one on the bestseller list last
week I said my even my voice changed
what do you mean I'm not on the best
seller this she said you're not on the
best seller list I'm sorry
she said your book
is I'm the best seller
[Music]
distinction there isn't it between
believing that this is me and
recognizing that you can let go a little
bit of of that listen to uh verse 66 of
the Dao why is the Sea King of a hundred
streams because it lies below them
humility gives it its power
that's a very important principle to
understand and I live
on the ocean right next to it it's my
front yard and always I watch it to
learn something from this thing called
the ocean which is the most powerful
source of life that we have on the
planet without it there's no life on
this planet and because it stays low so
what does this have to say to us
do you have the capacity to get past
that ego need to always be saying notice
me look how important I am I mean
there's been a proliferation of this
lately with this celebrity silly stuff
isn't it I mean CNN is doing you know
full hour shows on uh on silly little
things about what happened to this
particular celebrity or what happened to
that celebrity and the celebrities never
even done anything and it's there's all
of this talk about it and all of the new
magazines I mean and you look you go
into it through an airport and you look
on the newsstand and all the same photos
just with different magazines I don't
even know what what the names of all of
them are but there's like this huge
market now that we have for people to
get into a state of notice me Notice Me
notice me and how much do we train our
young people particularly in our schools
and so on that the one who is the star
is the one who gets the most attention
the one who is uh the most important and
the most valuable is the one that has uh
the most people liking them and so on
this constant obsession with needing to
be noticed when in fact
what I have found for myself is the
the happiest moments of my life are when
I can do it low and slow and not have
anybody out there even know what I'm
doing to be able to I mean Louise never
would have uh advertise the fact of some
of the things I talk about with her
generosity she does it anonymously it's
almost always done in those ways no look
at me look and notice me how important I
am and so on
so much to learn from that kind of
wisdom from that kind of interconnection
to the Dao the ability and the
willingness to say to do it anonymously
to say that you can just get done almost
anything that you want to get done if
you don't become obsessed with taking
credit for it remember the movie The
Magnificent Obsession
the movie made back I think in the 50s
and it was really about what was the
Magnificent Obsession it was the ability
to be able to give anonymously what is
Alcoholics Anonymous it is everybody
stays Anonymous nobody has a title
there's not even anybody in charge
there's nobody there's no leaders of
this there's no president there's no
vice president there's no organization
there's no it's just here's here's a
group of people who just want to help
other people whose lives are out of
control so here's a meeting place and
you come and some one day somebody will
will chair it and then somebody else
another day will share it and one of the
things I found and when I attend one of
these meetings
um is that I I feel you'll see so many
people who are down trodden
who feel
as if their life has passed them by who
look like they don't have any teeth they
haven't shaved they're they're dirty
they're
um
God in Disguise Mother Teresa was asked
the question about what she does when
she was in Calcutta and she said every
day every day I see Jesus Christ
in all of his distressing disguises all
of his distressing disguises that you
can see this Source you can see the dial
you can see it when particularly in
those who are the most obscure the most
uh
isolated from everyone else and whenever
I go to one of those meetings and I hear
people get up and they tell their
stories
they
I I always I feel that I feel there's so
much presence of the source of God of
spirit of Lao Tzu of this of the sort of
Dao whatever you want to call it in one
of those meetings than I've ever felt in
any church
I've I've never felt the presence of it
more and I encourage you any of you
watching this right now
go to one of those meetings you don't
have to be an alcoholic you don't have
to I'm not an alcoholic I don't call
myself an alcoholic I was never out of
control I drank but I wasn't out of
control and I uh but I still go to those
meetings I have people in my own family
that have struggled with addiction and I
go with them and I sit there and I
listen to those stories and I just I get
shivers down my back when I think about
how beautiful it is to be in the
presence of people all they want to do
is help each other there's a movie
called my name is Bill W
ow James Woods playing Jim Carr James
Garner isn't it and uh he his life just
got totally out of control with
addictions totally out of control and
then he went to a uh uh he he went to
one of these meetings and he began to
realize and he said we can we can
actually take these uh
these people and all we have to do is
all we have to do is love them all we
have to do is and he's so excited about
the concept of being able to go out
there and and offer it and I keep
referring to Louise because
she's such a hero to me
um there was a time back in the 80s when
our president wasn't even able to say
the word AIDS was he I mean he could
come on and here was this lady who
before this thing became the worldwide
phenomenon that it is was having
meetings in her own house and going and
bringing these people these downtrodden
people who had been labeled outcasts in
society and offering them a place to
learn how to love each other and to care
for each other this was long before
there was any celebrity State status
associated with trying to end this
horrible crisis that our country has and
our world has had
there was uh James Wood so excited about
the idea of we can create a place where
we're Anonymous nobody has to know
anything about us we don't have to say
our names we don't have to say anything
we just have to come there and we can
help each other and before that happened
everybody who got out of control with
addictions particularly with alcohol
would
would die there was no cure there was no
cure and where did they find their cure
they found it in being anonymous they
found it in being obscure they found it
in having no organization they found it
in having no elected representative they
founded it having no rules there are no
rules you just come and we care if
you've been one day or one hour sober or
even if you're drunk you come we care
about you and you are not that alcohol
who you are is this Divine soul in the
36th verse of the doubted Ching it says
the gentle
Outlast the strong
the Obscure outlasts the obvious
try to become a little more obscure a
little less interfering a little less
notice me a little less you know one of
the specific kinds of things that you
can do is just as you're about when
somebody else is talking just as you're
about to interject what you've been
thinking about for the whole time
waiting for them to stop talking
just to just stop and to bite your
tongue and say tell me more or that's
very interesting I have never heard that
point of view before even if they
totally completely disagree with
everything that you stand for to be to
be willing to listen to being able to
stop practice it I practiced it when I
did these verses of the Tao I practice
it every single day while I was working
on that just staying obscure and for me
that's not always so easy because of
just being recognized wherever I go and
if I saw someone who's about to
recognize me I would just put my head I
would just walk a little bit past them
like something right now I just want to
be anonymous right now I want to be
obscure
the Dao says storms always end verse 23
Fierce Winds Don't Blow all morning
a downpour of rain doesn't last all day
who does this Heaven and Earth
you're already connected to everything
you want or need
it will come to you at the exact perfect
time as the rivers and the streams come
to the ocean at the perfect time and
place
you've got to trust you got to know it's
going to come to you you don't have to
chase after it you can become a little
less obsessed with your ego and your
self-importance and who you are and what
you've done and you can get so much more
done and you know what it's the most
peaceful and sweet delicious way it's
like the song that Cecilia was singing
about the rose
there is an energy in the universe there
is something that is in each and every
one of us
and it's also in the universe and you
are connected to it in a way that is
often uh perceived to be uh oh aloof
from us because it's invisible because
it's in the world of what we call Spirit
the world that is not Material
and I would like to suggest that you
suspend your disbelief allow yourself to
know that you're not a human being here
having a spiritual experience
but that is the other way around
that you're a spiritual being
having a human experience
and the quality of your Human Experience
is really much more dependent upon how
you use this invisible intelligence and
how you connect to this energy
and once you have an awareness that you
can never be separate from it that you
and it and whatever you call it it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you
call it God if you call it divine
presence if you call it Soul if you call
it spirit
if you call it Consciousness if you call
it Christ Consciousness you can call it
Buddha Consciousness you can call it
Louise you can call it Edna you can call
it Ralph
Alan Watts once said that you can't get
wet from the word water
it isn't the word that allows you to
experience water and whatever it is that
you call it is something that is
distinct from what it is
when I was walking in here this evening
on these beautiful grounds I saw some
people looking at the flowers and the
different plants that were growing and
as they were looking at them there was
one person who was obviously an expert a
botanist of some kind and he was trying
to explain to each one of the people
what the name was the technical name for
each one of the flowers and I was
watching that and thinking it doesn't
matter what you call it can't you enjoy
look at that thing it's orange and it
just came out of nowhere there's
something very profound about enjoying
it and being there with it rather than
being obsessed with labeling it there
was a very famous Danish Theologian his
name was Soren Kierkegaard
he once said that once you label me
you negate me
once you place a label on me and and put
me into a compartment or a category of
some kind I must then become what it is
that you have labeled me to be
so that we want to be
able to live our lives and to practice
principles of higher awareness without
being so consumed with what I call
ordinary human awareness
an ordinary human awareness is just the
recognition or the belief system that I
am a human being maybe I'm having a
spiritual experience I'm not quite sure
but higher human awareness
but sometimes in the East called City
awareness
in the west it's been called higher
Consciousness or Christ Consciousness
there's many names for it but when you
get Beyond just knowing yourself as this
body and this personality
and this thing that you inhabit and
begin to realize that who you are is
that which was never born
and can never die
when you recognize your Eternal self
and that's what this program is really
about it's really about recognizing the
power the energy the capacity to be able
to do what it says in some of the most
holy books that you've ever read
that even the least among you
can do all that I have done
and even greater things and that's not
just empty words from holy scriptures
that's a very powerful lesson that each
and every one of us can practice and
live every day what I'd like to suggest
to you and what this program is really
about is that there are higher levels of
awareness that are available to us
a level of awareness that allows us to
do things like and it may sound a bit
strange
but to manage the coincidences of Our
Lives
to be able to place our attention on
what it is that we would like to create
for ourselves in our lives to literally
have the power to know that if I think
about it and I keep it there and I keep
that picture firm Within Me
that there is an energy
a source a capacity
Within Me
that is in the universe and that is also
in me and that I can use this energy
that I can manage it
there are many ways to get the things
that we want for ourselves in our lives
but
basically it all begins with how we
choose to think
as you think
so shall you be
seven little words that I think are
perhaps the most important things that
we can learn and master in our lives
this old proverb notion that I become
what I think about all day long and once
you know
that what you think about is what
expands
you start getting real careful about
what you think about
you don't allow your thoughts to be on
anything that you don't want or that you
wouldn't want to have manifest or show
up for you in your life
Emerson said the ancestor to every
action
is a thought and you can look at every
spiritual tradition whether it's eastern
or western whether it's ancient or
modern whether it's civilized quote or
uncivilized quote whether it's Tribal
and there is
in all of these Persuasions this idea
that inside each and every one of us
in a place that is not
material in a place that has no
dimensions in a place that has no
boundaries that in each and every one of
us we have this power
and we have this intelligence and you
can never see it I've often said that
when you die
if you're going to die and five minutes
before you're ready to leave they weigh
your body
and let's say it weighs
oh let's pick a good number 150 pounds
all right
and then life leaves your body
and they weigh your body instantly after
you're dead and it still weighs 150
pounds so that your body weighs the same
alive
or dead before it begins to deteriorate
and if that's the case then your life
this thing that leaves your body and
your body still weighs the same
is weightless
your life is weightless
you can't put a dimension on it you
can't put a measure on it Who You Are
is that life and that life is not in the
dimension of material
it's like if I want to wiggle my finger
I just have to have a thought and the
thought says I think I'm going to wiggle
my finger and then I do this and you say
well that's really no big deal
but it really is a big deal because
there's something invisible in here that
says I'm going to wiggle my finger I've
never seen that
I've never been able to you can't you
can put that under an x-ray you can try
to measure that and find out what it is
in there that allows you to say I'm
going to wiggle my finger and you can
never find it it's not in this world if
you will
so I can do all the scientific studies
and what I can do when I do these
scientific studies is I can find the
command center
inside of me that a lot and I can go to
the brain and I can point to a specific
point And scientists can do this and say
there's the command center which allows
you to have a thought I think I'm going
to wiggle my finger
but there's no computer and there's no
scientists and there's no technology
that can ever allow us to go inside and
say
there's the commander
in the command center
can't find it
and that commander in the command center
that weightlessness
is the part of us that we just don't pay
enough attention to
and what I'd like to suggest here this
evening is that once you start becoming
aware of the power of thought
and if you look around just look around
you at everything that you see it all
began with a thought
we become what we think about
and that is probably one of the most
important principles in learning to
manifest but in my mind as I think about
this idea of getting what you really
want
and being able to attract it into your
life
what what we have to look at is
basically the obstacles
that we have conditioned ourselves
and you notice I say that we have
conditioned ourselves because I have
never believed that we need to be
putting the responsibility on someone
else if you're conditioned it's because
you have allowed yourself to become that
and if we are conditioned if we
conditioned ourselves to believe certain
kinds of things
and one of the things that we kind of
believe and hang on to and live with is
this whole idea that uh
all of the things that happened to me in
my past
are what are keeping me from doing what
I'd like to do today
so we hang on to these things and we
fill ourselves with blame we say I'm the
middle child
I'm the youngest child I'm the oldest
child you know
I'm an only child
any one of those is a great excuse you
know if you're the youngest child you
can say well you know I never how could
I be making decisions for myself and be
a fully a fully functioning person today
when I always had somebody else telling
me what to do my whole life how could I
think for myself if you're the oldest
child you can simply say to yourself
well how could I be expected to think
for myself I always had to think for
somebody else I was always doing it for
somebody else and that leaves the middle
child you know the classic identity
crisis oh poor me my mother didn't even
know my name
she's always calling me by this one's
name or that one's name
so I don't know where I fit in so that
takes care of everybody except the only
child
and of course the only child
wow
your parents looked at you and said we
won't be doing that again
you have to live with that I don't huh
so everybody with their birth order or
with their mother like their sister
better or that we had enough or we
didn't have enough or we had too much or
we lived in the north we lived in the
South I'm Too Tall I'm too short I've
got too much hair I don't have enough
hair it's falling out it's not falling
out whatever it is we all have these
excuses and I call all of these things
that we hang on to and use to keep
ourselves from reaching these higher
places in our lives the wake
I call it the wake
and the wake
is uh comes from a story that I heard
Alan Watts tell one time and it's a very
powerful story
he said your life is like a boat
and it's heading up the river at say 40
knots all right
and as it's going you are somehow able
to metaphorically stand on the stern the
back of the boat and look down into the
water now there goes your life in this
direction and you're standing here and
you're looking down into the water and
you ask yourself these three questions
the first question
what is the wake
what is it what is this thing that you
see
and the answer
the wake is the trail
that is Left Behind
that's what it is nothing more nothing
less it's the trail that is Left Behind
second question to ask yourself in this
little metaphor what's driving the boat
what's making this thing go in this
direction
the answer
the present moment energy
that's being generated
by the engine
and nothing more that's the only thing
that's making the boat go in this
direction
and in this little scene this means it's
the present moment thoughts that I have
and how I am using them that is making
my life go in this direction and nothing
more because the third question is the
most important and Powerful question and
I've ever ever since I heard it I've
always thought about this whenever I
have a tendency to look back here and
blame something
is it possible
for the wake
to drive the boat
that is Hannah trail that is Left Behind
make a boat go in this direction
and of course the answer to that is no
it can't it's just a trail that is left
behind and in that trail there are an
enormous number of things and every one
of us has awake and we have a whole lot
of stuff in it and one of the problems
that we have
is that we have a tendency to look at
the wake and all of the stuff that's in
it to explain why it is my life isn't
working the way I would like it to work
so that um
you can take a look at the experiences
of your life I look at the experiences
of my life
and the experiences of my life I spent
some years in a series of foster homes
people have said to me ugh living in a
foster home that must have been terrible
I said no
it wasn't terrible at all when you're
six years old you don't wake up every
day and say oh my God I'm living in a
foster home isn't this awful poor me how
come me and nobody else you don't do
that you don't do that until you're 40.
[Music]
and when you're 40 and your life isn't
working and you're bankrupt and you're a
drug addict and and and you're falling
your relationships are all falling apart
and your family's leaving you and you
say why is this happening to you what do
you expect from me I had to live in a
foster home my mother liked my sister
better we were to this we were to and so
it's like we take a look at all of these
things in our wake and I'm not saying
here that you shouldn't be in touch with
your past and all of the things that are
back there but to use it as excuses for
why you can't get where you'd like to
get today is something that you if you
do that you will never get to this place
that I'm talking about in this program
which is this place that I call higher
awareness Way Beyond ordinary human
awareness one of the most powerful
lessons that you can ever learn
I had to learn as a Young Man
my own father was a man who walked away
he left he left home when I was just a
baby
left my mother
was sitting right here
107 years old is that what you know
82 years old though
and with three little boys
and all I had ever heard when he walked
out about this person that my older
brothers told me about and that when my
mother got her family back together
again when I was nine years old and did
all that she could to
to make a family again
with all the hardships this is a man who
never made a phone call
who never sent a penny who spent some
time in prison
who is an alcoholic who died of
cirrhosis of the liver the age of 49 and
was buried in a pauper's grave
in Biloxi Mississippi
and it wasn't until I went to his grave
and was able to stand there
and I used to dream about this man and
have this enormous hatred for this
person whom I had never seen just based
upon what he had done to my own mother
and to my brothers and so on and all of
the stories that I had heard and all the
research that I had done and I ended up
at his grave 10 years after he had died
when I finally found out that he was
dead
it was on the 27th of August
it was 1974.
and what I did
transformed my life
what I did is I believe I was sent there
by God or whatever you want to call that
Divine spirit that divine presence
and my life at that time wasn't working
I was overweight my relationships
weren't working my writing wasn't
working there were a lot of things that
weren't going well for me in my life at
that time not badly but they weren't
going at the level that I knew I was
capable of getting to because I was
filled with this hatred this anger this
bitterness
and so what I did is I stood there on
his grave on this little marker in the
ground
and I said
from now on I send you love I forgive
you
Mark Twain said that forgiveness is the
fragrance that the Violet sheds on the
heel that has crushed it
and once I let go of that anger and that
hatred and all of my attachment to the
bonding that I had done with these
wounds
and let go of that and cleared that out
of my life
my writing began to take place at a much
higher level in fact I wrote erroneous
zones in very very short time after that
I began to get myself back in shape I
began to eat better I began exercising
keeping my got my weight down and the
people that were supposed to come into
my life like my beautiful wife who sits
here with me this evening and all of our
children some of whom are here this
evening
all of it was allowed to flow when I
released that
that energy of negativity
and blame and hatred
they say that you never die from a snake
bite
it isn't the bite
and you can't be unbitten it's in the
wake
what kills you is the Venom that
continues to pour through you long after
the bite has taken place and that's
something we have control over and we
can't change
and I'd like to suggest that what
happens is that many of us Bond
ourselves to these wounds of our past if
I were to cut my hand just cut it
and watch it my nature says
flows up the wound
and I just have to watch it and there's
no doctor out there there's no medicine
out there that's going to heal that
wound there's something there's a
healing stream that I am connected to
that will allow that wound to heal so my
nature says close up the wounds don't
bond to them don't hang on to them close
them up
but supposing I say to myself oh no you
don't there's no way I'm going to let
you close up
you see if I can keep you open and I can
go to you and say look at this say what
happened wow look at this cut I've got
oh you poor thing look at that it seems
to be getting worse it's getting
infected isn't that terrible and if you
practice this kind of a mentality when
your nature says close up the wound but
you keep it open before long you lose
your hand
and after that you'll lose your arm and
the whole organism will be destroyed if
you don't let your nature take over and
your nature also says close up the
wounds of your past close them up
and oftentimes we ignore our nature
I had a great teacher that came into my
life
through his writing his name was
nisargadata Maharaja lived in India up
until the mid-1980s
and he wrote something called I am that
which was very powerful and influential
in my life
and one of the things that he talked
about when he was asked the question
what's the difference between say a
saint or a highly functioning human
being a spiritual Master a spiritual
teacher
and the rest of us is that they have
unconditional love in them
and you don't or we don't and he said no
he said
Saints have unconditional love in them
and so do you
he said the difference between ordinary
human awareness and higher awareness
people is that they have nothing else
inside of them that's all they have
and it's almost like we have to learn
how to get that in ourselves to be able
to well I always like to use a metaphor
of an orange I love the orange
perhaps living in Florida is why but
an orange is a simple metaphor you take
this orange and you squeeze it as hard
as you can squeeze it and you ask
yourself
what will come out
and what comes out when you squeeze an
orange
juice
never no matter how many times you
squeeze it will apple juice come out
there's no mistakes you'll never get
grapefruit juice out of this thing ever
the only thing you'll ever get out of it
is orange juice and the next question is
why why wouldn't you squeeze an orange
as hard as you can squeeze it does
orange juice come out
and I asked that question up in Toronto
one time this little girl sitting right
in the front row she said that's dumb
it's a she said
she said it
how you are really smart and she smiled
and she thought that was great but
that's the truth the reason that orange
juice comes out when you squeeze is
because that's what's inside now you
extend the metaphor and someone squeezes
you
that is someone says something about you
that you don't like someone behaves
towards you in a way that you find
offensive somebody does something or
says something to you that you feel hurt
by and out of you
comes anger
hatred bitterness tension fear anxiety
stress
and immediately you say the reason that
comes out of me is because of how he
said it or the way that she said that or
because they did that but the truth is
the reality is that what comes out
is what's inside
and if you don't like
what's inside you can change it now if
you ask me how does orange juice get
inside of an orange I would say
I don't know I can't figure it out
it's a mystery to me I just enjoy the
oranges of my life and give God the
credit for that
a lot of people think that other things
make them the way they are they will
blame their past they'll blame their
parents they'll blame the economy
they'll blame the Ayatollah they'll
blame somebody for things that are going
wrong in their life and one of the
favorite things that we have to blame
for why I'm upset at a particular moment
is something called traffic traffic made
me upset and I've always reminded myself
when I'm in a gym or when I'm on the
freeway and I'm trying to get someplace
the traffic doesn't care that you have
within you the opportunity in this
moment to really work on these things
that are perhaps debilitating or
creating anxiety or stress in your life
that these are tests these are
opportunities for you traffic doesn't
care your anger is your choice and you
can always choose to be the be happy
angry depressed miserable upset or you
can choose to be fulfilled and do
something positive In This Moment it's
always up to you
I'd like to give you
what I think of as the great spiritual
teachings
of many various
Persuasions
there's a story that summarizes it
it's the story of what I call the four
philanthropists in a village
the
conquerors had come through and they had
taken all of the men or many of the men
who were warriors at the time
and they had placed them into this
prisoner of war camp right in the
village
and many of the villagers knew that
their compatriots were imprisoned and
the first philanthropist
was a person who had great wealth
and he went to the people who had the
prison
and were in charge of it and he said to
them
I understand the men are not able to
have fresh water and cold water I would
like to donate all of my earnings and
everything that I have to purifying the
water for them and making sure that all
of them will not be sick
and he was granted that and he felt like
he had fulfilled his destiny that he had
done what he was here for
the second philanthropist discovered
that the men were sleeping on rocks
and that they were cold at night they
didn't have blankets and he took all of
his funds and he said to them I would
like to provide bedding
and blankets for the people so that they
will be comfortable
when they sleep at night and he was
granted that right and he donated his
money for this purpose and again he felt
that he was fulfilling his destiny
the third philanthropist discovered that
the food that they were eating
was inadequate that they were just given
uh beans and and
water and some bread and so he said I
own a farm
and I'd like to grow all of my food and
I'd like to take this food to all of
these prisoners and he was granted that
right and all three of these great
philanthropists in the village felt that
they had really completed their mission
for why they were here
but the fourth philanthropist was a
saint
he was living not at ordinary human
awareness but at higher Consciousness
levels
and he went and he found out where the
keys were
and he went to the prison at night
and he released
all of the prisoners
and this little metaphorical story
really tells us that when we are living
at ordinary human awareness there's
nothing wrong with those who are out
there who can help us to suffer in
Comfort all right and many of us have
learned to do that and accept that and
say all right as long as I'm comfortable
even if I'm suffering it's okay but
there are those who have keys
and those keys can open the prisons
one of the great teachers in my life was
Carlos Castaneda
and Castaneda talked about his teacher
who was what they call inaugural
a and a Native American term that refers
to all that is knowable
and
he
his teacher told him that your
life is like being born into a a room a
mansion if you will that has a thousand
rooms but you're born into one room and
this one room is called
daily human awareness and the only way
you can get in is through conception
and birth you're in and the only way you
can get out
we are taught
is to die
so we spend our lives in this mansion in
one room even those there's 999 other
rooms we don't know how to get out into
those rooms unless we die so we wait to
die
and what his teacher told him is I can
teach you how to get out of the room of
daily awareness
and into the other 999 rooms and if you
stay with me
and learn all that I have to give you
I can teach you how to get out of the
house all together
without having to die
and what we have to do in order to get
to that place where we can take the keys
and unlock the self-imposed prisons or
the prisons that we have given ourselves
on the basis of what we have come to
believe is our limitations what we can
and can't do we have to let go of that
and I call it rewriting our agreement
with reality we literally have to make a
a whole new contract with what it is
that I perceive to be what is possible
for me
and in order to do that we have to shift
out of the things that we have come to
believe in and everything that you came
to this program watching tonight that
you believe in was handed to you by
someone else outside of you
was handed to you by the experiences or
testimony of someone in the past and
because it comes from outside of you
there is still an element of doubt
and this element of Doubt isn't bad but
it keeps you from reaching higher levels
because what you think about is what
expands and if you're thinking doubt
then doubt is what expands
William Blake said if the Sun and Moon
should ever doubt they would immediately
go out
so how do we get past what we believe in
or what has been handed to us and still
honor it and be grateful for all of the
teachers and all of the people who have
come before us
so what we have to learn to do is let go
of that tribal Consciousness and shift
to what I call a knowing now there's a
big difference between what you believe
and what you know
everything that you know is something
that you have made conscious contact
with
conscious contact
so there's nobody out there watching
there's nobody in this world who knows
how to swim
who learned it by somebody else telling
them that you can swim or by watching
Mark Spitz go through the water or by
observing other people doing it
you may remove some of the doubt but you
will never know how to swim until you
get in the water and blob around a few
times and then do it and then you'll
have a knowing and that knowing is
something that you'll never lose it's
like riding a bicycle or dancing the
Macarena or making a lemon meringue pie
or anything that you know how to do it's
because you've made conscious contact
and I'd like to suggest that there's a
big difference between knowing about
a divine presence knowing about a sacred
awareness knowing about God
and knowing god
there's a big difference just like
there's a big difference between knowing
about the possibility of being able to
heal myself of something that is
bothering me perhaps a disease process I
perhaps May believe that it's possible
because I've read other people and I've
heard others say it
and I've read the testimony and I've
listened to the tapes and I've gone to
the seminars
but until you have made conscious
contact with it
you'll never know it
and I'd like to suggest there are
there's a wonderful poem
I'd like to share this poem with you
it's written by a wonderful woman
her name is Valerie Cox
and she lives up in Seattle and she's
written quite a bit of poetry
this particular poem really speaks to me
through the difference between what you
know and what you believe in
immerse yourself in this in these words
a woman was waiting at an airport one
night with several long hours before her
flight she hunted for a book in the
airport shop bought a bag of cookies
and found a place to drop
she was engrossed in her book but
happened to see that the man beside her
as bold as could be grabbed a cookie or
two
from the bag between which she tried to
ignore to avoid a scene
cheap Munch cookies and watched the
clock as this gutsy Cookie Thief
diminished her stock
she was getting more irritated as the
minutes ticked by thinking if I wasn't
so nice I'd blackened his eye
with each cookie she took he took one
too
and when only one was left she wondered
what he'd do
with a smile on his face and a nervous
laugh he took the last cookie
and broke it in half
he offered her half as he ate the other
she snatched it from him and thought Oh
Brother this guy has Sumner and he's
also Rude why he didn't even show any
gratitude
she had never known when she had been so
galled and sighed with relief when her
flight was called she gathered her
belongings and headed to the gate
refusing to look back at the thieving
ingrate
she boarded the plane and sank in her
seat then sought her book which was
almost complete
as she reached in her baggage she gasped
with surprise
there was her bag of cookies in front of
her eyes
I love that I love that
if mine are here she moaned with this
bear then the others were his and he
tried to share
Too Late to Apologize she realized with
grief that she was the rude one the
ingrate
the thief
the Cookie Thief
and all of us in some ways are cookie
thieves
I have eight beautiful children our
youngest little girls
eight years old one of the things that
you do when you become enlightened and
become a guru
like me
that'll be the day
is when we place something that is
important to know where it is we
practice mindfulness
so that we never misplace anything
so obviously having reached this exalted
level of awareness in my home with my
eight children I never misplace anything
So I placed my keys right here in a
certain spot
but my little girl has this wonderful
habit of taking my keys and hiding them
I'm daddy in the morning
so that she can watch me
flip out
as I look for the keys and I'll say sage
how many times has daddy told you don't
hide my keys in the morning daddy you
told me not to do it I don't hide your
keys anymore come on where'd you put my
keys the last time they were in your
dial house where did you put daddy you
told me not to do it and then of course
my 12 year old daughter Serena loves to
just assume this stance
she's watching me raise my voice she'll
say I wonder what all those people would
think of Mr positive if they could see
him right now
get lots of reminders
foreign
look when I come back out here I want
those keys here and I go back and I get
my clothes on and I reach in my back
pocket and there are my keys
right where I had left them the night
before in my pocket
and there's a fine line I think between
being a guru
and being a jerk all right
and I probably crossed that line more
times than I should be admitting here on
television
but this idea of being a Cookie Thief
and creating a knowing a knowing is
something
I did a benefit uh along with my wife a
couple of years ago with a man on Maui
whose name is Michael Canal who had been
injured in a uh in an accident he's a
quadriplegic or paraplegic and at that
meeting when I was over there was a a
man who lived on another one of the
islands who was known as a Kahuna
A Healer an ancient healer from
Polynesia and he was introduced to me
and he said that was a nice talk and so
on and I said how do you get to be a
Kahuna you know do you take Kahuna 101 I
mean what courses do you take how does
this work up and he said no he said
kahunas are raised to have no doubt
to have no doubt to have a knowing
and he said when I when a knowing
confronts a belief in a disease process
The Knowing will always Triumph and that
knowing is something in which you say
you are healed and healing takes place
one of the great stories of knowing is
again with our little girl Sage who uh
we were
spending the summer
in our summer home and we went to visit
this dermatologist and sage has had this
thing called Flat warts for the last uh
well since she was two and a half years
old from Two and a Half until seven
which is over four years she had these
flat warts and not only did she have
them around her face around her mouth
and around her nose but they were
getting worse they were moving up and
they were getting up around her eyes and
so on and would notice that that they
were getting progressively worse even
though all of the places that we had
taken her had said they will go away
she'll outgrow them but it didn't seem
to be that way and they always said it
would be a few months well years had
gone by and she still hadn't so we were
over my friends uh this dermatologist on
uh in Kihei and he um
I said Kenny as long as we're here would
you mind taking a look at uh at Sage my
wife was there and he took these big
white light and he put it in her face
and he said you've got flat warts
she hates that term she never wanted to
call them flat watch she calls them her
bumps all right she just called them her
bums so uh
he said to her but the good news is that
when you get married you won't have them
well she's seven and a half going who is
this dork you've got me talking to now
and then he said to her something he
said you know we can't burn them off and
there's no medicine that we can give
them but he did say something to the
effect that the ability to rid yourself
of these things is within yourself
and that if you can call upon that
healing capacity in you
and begin to talk to these bumps
in a way in which you ask them to leave
that you have a much greater chance of
getting rid of them faster than anything
that I could give you and we certainly
can't burn them off because we might Sky
your pretty face and that's basically
the message that he gave us I'm
paraphrasing it
so we went back that night to where we
were staying and there was a whole bunch
of kids there as there always are when
uh when we're seeing all their friends
were there and we walked into the
bedroom and it was late at night and
over in the corner in a on her air
mattress was Sage and she had the
blankets pulled up over her head
and she had a flashlight underneath the
blankets
and I went over and I lifted up the
blanket I said honey is everything all
right she said
I'm talking to my bumps
and I left the room and I came into my
wife or in the other bedroom I said
honey you're not going to believe this
but
age is in there talking to her
to her great
the third night the same thing now that
was third on Friday this happened on
Monday on Friday
as God is my witness on television
every single one of those bumps was gone
and has never reappeared since
a knowing you see there is a stream of
healing
that is something that we can plug into
it's very much like electricity people
say well in ancient Greece there was no
electricity there was electricity
we just didn't plug into it that's all
and there's a stream of healing and when
we go into that stream of healing with a
knowing we go to a higher level within
ourselves and we don't allow any doubt
in
basically in every single one of us
every human being out there there are
two of us there's two people
the first person in each person is
called the ego or I call it the ego
e-g-o Earth guide only all right this is
the part of us that says who I am is
separate from you separate from God
separate from my environment and
therefore I am in competition with and
my value is based upon how much I get
how much my stuff is worth how much
better looking I might be or how much
more attractive I might be how much more
money I might have the value of my
possessions and so on what is mine
so it's not mystical awareness which
says I am connected it is
that individual lower level of awareness
which says my ego
this is mine
also in each and every one of us there's
another person
and this other person
is called what I call the sacred self
or the higher self and this sacred or
higher self really doesn't care how much
you get it doesn't care who you're
better than it doesn't care how much
stuff you have it's not interested in
any of that
the problem is that we very seldom
listen to it we pay very little
attention to it this higher or sacred
part of us wants only one thing
it wants us to be
at peace
at peace
whatever choice you make in every
interaction you have make the choice to
be at peace your sacred or higher self
says whereas your ego says oh no no no
it's much more important to be right
and so we find people in relationships
struggling struggling a lot and one of
the things that they struggle about is
who's right and who's wrong most of the
fights that you have in your
relationships really basically when you
oftentimes you forget the details but
it's basically about who's right and
who's wrong so that if you want to have
your higher or your sacred part of you
ruling in your life I suggest this to
you
practice being kind
rather than right
when you have the choice and you have
the choice in your relationships with
your spouse and your ex-spouse with your
parents with your grandparents with your
in-laws
with strangers on the freeway with
flight attendants with Waiters with
whomever you interact if you can just
subdue this ego part of you which says
it's important for me to be right which
will introduce you to stress and anxiety
and fear and so much of the stuff that I
talked about earlier and instead say
how can I suspend this part of me
and allow the
allow the part of me that wants to be at
peace that wants to be happy that wants
to be fulfilled and if I said to you I'm
going to give you a magic wand and with
this magic wand
I am going to allow you to just wave it
and get anything that you want whatever
you want you could have this you can
have this car you can have this these
the nice clothes over here you can have
this home whatever it is or I said to
you in lieu of that I'm going to give
you another one and you can waive this
and for every moment for the rest of
your life
you'll be at peace whatever comes along
you will be able to choose peace
and basically we know that we're only
here for a very short time
and being able to choose peace which is
what the sacred part of you begs you the
higher self
once you get that you begin to shift
away and you stop telling yourself that
the people who are close to me in
relationship with me are the people who
don't belong there
I remember my wife and I we often talk
about this and we we've been together a
long time we've had many children
together and we have a very wonderful
loving relationship thank you
but
we'd often and one time I said to her or
she said to me you know we love each
other but this doesn't sound like love
sometimes the way we talk to each other
doesn't sound like love let's practice
let's practice with each other being
kind rather than being right and it was
transformative that that when we had
that walk that and doing that with your
children and doing that with a waiter I
mean a waiter who comes to you and is
like you know hassled and frazzled and
has been busy and all of that and your
ego says wait a minute I'm here and I'm
important and I have a right to be
served and I have a right to be served
now
that's the ego part of you if this if
you can suspend that and say you know
you are a lucky man tonight
you've got somebody who's stealing from
his sacred self
and I understand and you take your time
and you come to me and you bring it at
your convenience whenever you can I'm
willing to I'm willing to suspend you
know what you'll get served so fast and
with such gratitude
just for being kind if you practice it
every single one of us
are in relationship
whether it's with our husbands and wives
with our ex-husbands and wives with our
children our grandchildren
whether it's with people we drive along
the freeway next to whether it's with
waiters and waitresses or baggage
handlers or flight attendants or people
that we are in line to get into the
movie
we're all in relationships and we'd
interact with each other all the time
and probably the best lesson that I've
ever learned in my life about how to be
in a relationship in a way which is
powerful and happy and fulfilling is to
remember this sentence when you have a
choice
and you always do
to be right
or to be kind
start picking kind
the ego part of us wants to be right
how dare you not serve me as fast as I
think I deserve to be served how dare
you say something to me and immediately
we want to make that other person wrong
and make ourselves right but there's a
part of each one of us
that wants to be happy he wants to be at
peace and that part of us says it
doesn't matter whether you're right it
doesn't matter about your ego all you
want is to be at peace so pick kind
this kind of an attitude if we had more
of this not only in our own personal
lives would we improve virtually every
relationship we have with all of the
people closest to us and all of the
strangers we interact with but on our
planet as well we would begin to
understand the wisdom that on a round
Planet there's no choosing upsides that
we're all one we're all breathing the
same air
we're all drinking the same water we're
all being warmed by the same Sun
and as they say as the Native Americans
used to say no tree has branches so
foolish as to fight among themselves it
applies in your relationships and it
applies as a people as well
I've often said that
in any relationship
in which two people
agree on everything
one of them is unnecessary all right
so
it isn't about getting somebody who's
just like you in fact your soulmate is
the person that you have a lot of
difficulty with your soul makes the
person you can't get rid of that just
keeps showing up
you you say this they say that and there
they are they're back again and they
never go away they keep showing up in
your life and everybody has these people
these are our greatest teachers because
anybody in your life who can push a
button and send you into a frenzy
is the person who's your greatest
teacher you know why
because they teach you that you haven't
mastered yourself at this moment
you don't know how to choose peace and
of course in Miracles there's a
wonderful line that says I can choose
peace rather than this
whatever it is I can choose peace
my soul mate my wife is one of my
soulmates I mean she knows how to push
those buttons she's really good at it
and she's one of my greatest teachers I
remember saying to her one time honey do
you love me
for who I am or for what I've been able
to do for you I just wanna she said that
you call yourself a spiritual person I
can't believe you would even ask a
question like that
she said I don't love you for what you
can buy for me or what success that
you've had or where you are in any
bestseller list I love you for who you
are and I will always love you I said
well I was just asking I said what if I
was just Joe six-pack you know and I was
just bringing home you know a meager
salary and so on she said I will always
love you for who you are
she said I would miss you
but I would always love you
she knows she's got that
[Music]
and all of us have soul mates my
daughter Serena
who's just turned 13. Martini Bopper
she came home from school one day she
said there's a rumor in our school
she saw somebody had seen me on
television that you actually wrote a
book
about how to raise children tell me it
isn't true
I said honey you can come and hear me
speak would you like to come and hear me
speak I said people actually pay to hear
me speak she said why
I mean she's she's got that all right
she's just but her soulmate is her
sister summer who is now almost 15. but
when Serena was 12 and summer was 14 my
wife was away working on a book of hers
and I was taking care of everything at
home while she was working on her book
about a spiritual approach to childbirth
and infancy care and she's as qualified
as anybody to write about that I can
tell you and I was making breakfast I
was making waffles for them in the
morning at the toaster and uh
she mixes all this stuff up it's a lot
easier to just put them in and summer
and Serena were sitting at the back
table in the kitchen
and I heard summer say to Serena
out of nowhere about 6 30 in the morning
if you didn't have any feet
would you wear shoes
and I turned around I said
where is this going
and Serena went that's ridiculous what
do you mean if I didn't have any feet
would I wear shoes she said of course
not
summer said to her
then why are you wearing that bra
everybody's got a soul mate
stormed out of the room there was a
but it isn't the people who agree with
us it isn't the people who tell us the
right thing it isn't the people who
always find us you know just perfectly
smelling good and so on there is an
element of understanding that everybody
who shows up in our life has something
to teach us many people have said to me
that they have observed in my writing
and in my teaching over the years that I
have
changed I've evolved if you will that
when I first wrote erroneous zones and
pulling your own strings and books like
this that I was really talking about
something much different that I'm
talking about today which is
spirituality higher awareness higher
Consciousness and it's true because one
of the great teachers again in my life
was Carl Jung and in Modern Man In
Search of a soul he said that there are
archetypes there are stages that we go
through when we reach adulthood he said
those stages
work like this
he said it starts out with the athlete
when you reach adulthood and he called
it the athlete not as a put down of
athletes but as the time in our adult
life when our primary emphasis is on our
body what it can do how strong it is how
fast it can run how much it can lift how
beautiful it is and so on and we believe
that we are a body if you will perhaps
with a soul he said the second stage is
what he called the stage of the warrior
and this is the time in our adult life
when we take ourselves out of our
physical self if you will and we take
this body out into the world
and we do what Warriors do which we
attempt to conquer we attempt to defeat
we attempt to get as much as we can it's
the age of the ego it's the time when
we're saying what are my quotas what's
in it for me what can I get
and we go through that stage and I
believe that I was writing earlier in my
life
to teach people how to be better
athletes and better Warriors because
that's where I was in my life in those
days and the shift has taken place for
me as well Jung said that the third
archetype is what he called the
archetype of the of the Statesman or the
states woman and this is when we finally
get to a place in our adult life when we
stop saying what's in it for me
how much can I get how much can I
accumulate and we begin to ask the
question
how may I serve
what are your quotas and serving others
becomes much more important
than our own egos
until ultimately we reach what he called
the stage of the spirit the archetype of
the spirit when we finally begin to
recognize that
this is not our home
what it means in the Holy books when it
says you are in this world but you are
not of this world
and these four stages represent also
where we can look at our own self how am
I doing going through these to what
extent do I find myself consumed with my
own quotas what's in it for me how much
can I get
and ask ourselves that question as we
begin to interact and deal with other
people being able to manifest being able
to be attract into our lives what it is
that we'd like to attract into our lives
boils down to a formula that I'd like to
share with you here this evening and
this formula is one that everyone
and that I know who was able to get
things into their life practice is this
I call it the four release
all right so that what you really really
really really want
you will get
and these four really stand each of them
stands for something
and if you look at people who are good
at some people call them lucky some
people call them highly spiritual
whatever it might be but they are good
at getting what they want in their lives
and here are the four release the first
one says
I wish
so what you really wish for everything
that you'd like to get into your life
starts with a wish
it's a thought I wish I could get that
job I wish I could get that promotion I
wish I could lose weight I wish I could
get rid of that addiction that I have I
wish I could whatever it's a wish so
what you have to start with a wish
the second really stands for
what you desire
what you really wish and desire and the
difference between what you wish for and
desire is in what I call asking ask and
you shall receive ask
and you shall receive
it's not empty words be willing to ask
when I get stuck sometimes writing and
I'm just not quite sure where to go or
whatever I just leave the typewriter I
leave the yellow pad that I'm writing
and I walk over to the couch and I get
into a meditation and I say I would like
some help
in having this become clearer as to how
to express it and it's always there
sometimes the phone will ring and my
wife will call and she'll say did you
know that this was in the mail and I
said read it to me and it'll be exactly
what I needed sometimes it just comes in
the thing that I call an Intuition or an
Insight whatever it might be
the third really stands for
what I intend
so now you shift away from
what I
wish for and ask for and you frame it in
such a way that you intend to create it
I intend to create this
whatever it might be whether it's a
healing whether it's a losing of weight
whether it's getting rid of an addiction
whether it's creating Prosperity I
intend to create it and if you notice
people who are good at manifesting they
don't mince those kinds of words I will
do it and someone will say well what if
it doesn't work out you say well then
I'll just learn whatever I have to learn
from it not working out but I intend to
create this in my life there's an
intention and the intention is so
powerful that
you become independent of the good
opinion of other people you're not
checking it out with the tribe you're
not checking it out with what everybody
else out there said you should do or
shouldn't do you're saying to yourself
I intend to create it and I often tell
people don't tell anybody else about
what you want to manifest don't make it
a big statement
instead keep it to yourself and they say
why do you want to say that I say
because the minute that you do you
invoke ego
and in quantum physics there's a simple
line it says particles themselves are
not responsible for their own creation
another way of saying that is the way
Saint Paul said it that which is seen he
said hath not come from that which doth
appear that is the source of everything
over here it's not over here
it's in this invisibleness
and once you invoke ego you have to
defend it you have to explain it you
have to get the tribe involved in it and
before long you've lost the capacity to
manifest it's a spiritual
Journey
inspiration in spirit when you're
inspired in spirit
the fourth really
stands for passion
passion
that is I am absolutely passionate about
it and I intend to create it with that
love one of the great books that one of
my teachers sent to me from ancient
India written like 3 000 years ago
has a line in it that says to attempt to
manifest what you want without passion
is like dressing up a corpse
so you take this corpse and you put a
tuxedo on it and you dress it all up and
you put all the makeup on it and you
take it out into the world and you say
now see what you can get for me but
basically it's dead inside
and if it's dead inside that is if it
lacks passion if you lack passion you're
not going to be able to attract it into
your life so what you wish for ask for
intend to create
and have passion about you'll get
you'll get it
that's the good news
the bad news is
that what you really really really
really
don't want
you will also get
and this is one of the most difficult
things for people to understand and when
you're dealing with the tribe and you're
dealing with what is and what what
everybody else tells you is impossible
and somebody might be watching this and
say well that's just a lot of nonsense I
mean you can't just put your attention
on something think about it and have it
come true it involves a whole lot of
other stuff like that you see here's how
it works you cannot attract thin
for my hate being fat
because if what you think about is what
expands
and what you're thinking about is hating
being fat then hating being fat is what
you will continue to manifest you act
upon what you think about
you cannot attract Prosperity from an
inner Consciousness that says
I hate being poor I despise being poor
because if you despise being poor if
you're angry about being poor then being
angry about being poor or despising it
is what you will continue to act upon
and you'll be able to say see
now that's it gets worse
you cannot manifest what you want
if your attention is on what is
if your attention is on what is and the
circumstances of your life
that's where your thoughts are
then you will continue to create what is
into your life
you've got to figure out a way to get
your mental images your energy your
attention your higher awareness off of
what is and onto what you want and every
time your thoughts are on what is
you shifted to what do I want
and it's even worse than that
you cannot manifest what you want if
your attention is on what always has
been
this is the way things are you'll hear
people say it to you all the time these
are the circumstances of life don't you
understand this is reality wake up this
is the way things have always been
there's always been poor people you're
one of them
that's just the way it is
and you watch that person and being poor
continues to manifest into their life if
you keep your attention on what always
has been then what always has been is
what you'll continue to manifest as you
think so shall you be these aren't empty
words folks
this is reality and the worst and
ugliest of all
is this
you cannot manifest what you want into
your life no matter what it is if your
attention is on what they want for you
or what they expect for you or what they
tell you are your limitations or what
you can do because if your thoughts are
on what they want you cannot put your
attention on what you want what they
want will continue to manifest and you
might be in a tribe that always turns
left
and all you want to do is make a right
turn
and you go to all the tribal elders and
you say look I just want to make one
right turn and they say wait a minute in
our tribe we only turn left we've always
turned left that's the way this tribe
has always been
and so they will have an emergency
meeting
and they will convene all the elders to
get you to come to your senses
Jackson Browne has what I think one of
the great poets on our planet
great singer he has a song called for a
dancer in there there are words to this
effect he says just do the steps that
you've been shown by everyone you've
ever known until the dance becomes your
very own which is what most of us are
doing we're doing the steps that we've
been shown by everyone we've ever known
and the dance has become our very own
and later on in the song he says
something to the effect of into a dancer
you have grown from the seeds someone
else has thrown
go on ahead and throw some seeds of your
own somewhere between the time you
arrive
and the time you go home
and then the kicker it always gets to me
when I listen to this song
he said because in the end
there is one dance
you'll do alone
and it's like letting go of this
tendency to be a dancer to be doing the
steps that we've been shown by everyone
we've ever known and then it becomes our
own and then we pass it on and we pass
it on to break that chain we have to
shift our attention off of what we don't
want and onto what we do want and this
goes for everything
I was at a doing a book tour up in
Chicago
I get off the airplane and a woman picks
me up and she's got a doozy of a cold
like you know Snoopy's as my kids call
it coming out of her nose onto her dress
I mean it was and I was in a in this
little Honda with her for two days
and she so I said to her something to
the effect I can't remember what it was
I I know she didn't like it but I said
something to the effect of oh it's been
20 years since I've had a cold like that
and she said oh that's just what I
needed to hear
it's people like you who go around
telling us normal mortal human beings
that when we have a call we should be
feeling guilty she said I don't
appreciate that at all she said coals
are just things that happen to us I said
well
I understand that I said but I just
don't think like you she said well what
do you think
I said well tell me what you think
you're the one with the cold she said
well I think colds are viruses and that
they're in the air and they're going to
land on us every once in a while and
when they do we shouldn't be feeling
guilty about it and feeling bad about it
and people you like you writing books
about it to make us feel worse I said
look we're on the same page here
I said I believe just like you
I think that colds are in the air
and that they're viruses and that they
land on us she said well how come you
don't get a cold in I said because when
they land on me I talk to them
she said you talk to viruses
I said of course
she said well what do you say well I say
to her look you've landed on the wrong
immune system I'm not going to talk
about you to anyone
I'm not going to complain about you I'm
not going to give you any attention
and you're no room to flourish on this
immune system you're just not going to
do your work here but there's a lady in
Chicago
who's waiting for you
now you laugh and you think that that's
silly but I'm telling you that when you
keep your attention on what you don't
want what you don't want is what will
keep manifesting into your life
addictions have been described as never
getting enough of what you don't want
or what you despise
so we keep our attention on what we
don't want
and what we don't want is what we keep
seeking after and then we despise it
when we put our attention on what we do
want when we shift to a place called
unconditional love
and begin to view it as something that I
don't have to be dependent upon you can
shift right out of it the currency for
attracting what we want into our lives
is our thoughts as you think so shall
you be begin to place them on what it is
that you want and you'll start seeing it
shift
over and over again and people who are
terrific at getting what they want you
start getting inside of their head and
say what do you think like what how are
you organized in here and you know what
they always say
I never ever allow my thoughts on
anything that I don't want and no matter
who out there is saying yes but you
can't do this yes but you can't do that
I never allow that kind of energy I
don't I shift away from that energy
instantly that's what separates Great
masters from ordinary human awareness
I have been talking during this program
about a consciousness
and awareness a level of functioning or
living or thinking
which involves something that I call
spirituality it doesn't it doesn't it
isn't restricted in any religious way it
is a Divine intelligence an organizing
intelligence that is everywhere at once
some people call it God
some people call it soul
some call it spirit
back in the times of
slavery
there was a young man his name was John
Newton he was 23 years old
and he had what is called A in Japanese
it's called excuse my Japanese but it's
called satari
I'd love to say that
satuti s-a-t-o-r-i and it means instant
Awakening
the idea that you can create something
in your life
now
and Zen they have a proverb that says
when the student is ready the teachers
will appear so it's just being ready and
so you don't have to go through this
long involved process to get to
Enlightenment where you get it five
minutes before you die
instead you can have it when you are
ready the Native Americans they have a
word called natohi in the elute Indians
and it means great seeing like I don't
see I don't see I don't see an oh there
it is I see and it's like it's like in a
dream when you just have this Awakening
this light goes off and you just know
it's an intuition if you will intuition
has been described as you know if prayer
is you talking to God then intuition is
God talking to you it's like hearing
that voice and you know it and John
Newton this 23 year old sea captain had
a a ship full of uh human cargo that he
was bringing from the west coast of
Africa to the new world
as slaves and he had this Satora this
Awakening
and then this is a moment of Awakening
he realized that what he was doing was
horrible
and defenseless in terms of his own
inner sense of morality
and he wrote down on the
envelope
the words to a song
called he called it Grace
I once was lost
and now I'm found
and it was Grace
that taught my heart to feel it was
grace that brought me home he shifted
away from his material world and his his
being a warrior to being a spiritual
being in an instant which is available
to every single one of us
there have been things that have been
showing up in my life and principles for
me to write about and um
things for me to tell you and share with
you that have
that have really surprised me and I've
always lived by the principle of telopa
the 10th Century Sufi master
who said have a mind that is open to
everything
and attached nowhere attached to nothing
and
my wife and I always had this
attitude in bringing up our children
that keep an open mind and anything that
you immediately reject
get your ego out of that and just open
yourself to the words of Jesus in the
New Testament when he said with God
all things are possible
and I always ask my audience what does
that leave out
what is all things are possible leave
out
and obviously the answer is nothing
in the book that I wrote um
for the film The Shift there's also
called the shift
it has four chapters
from
ambition to meaning
moving Our Lives
away from our egos and into a place of
of meaning what Serena was up here
speaking about
it it's a sense of feeling that you're
making a difference in the world and
towards the end of that book I quoted
from
a man named Joel Goldsmith
who wrote the infinite way in
parentheses and Eternity and
we actually had friends on Maui a friend
on Maui named Alexandra
who's in her 90s and in her late 80s she
would go out kayaking every day
and she actually dated Joe Goldsmith
back in the 1950s when he lived on
Hawaii
he's been a very much of a hero to me
and then from his book parentheses in
parentheses in eternity which is
what your life is
a parentheses in eternity he said these
words
he said then there are those who reach a
stage in which they realize the futility
of this
constant striving and struggling for the
things that perish
things which after they are obtained
prove to be shadows
it is at this stage that some person's
term from the seeking for things in the
outer Realm
to a seeking for them from God
and that has been probably the major
shift in my life
taking the focus in my life off of
the things
the accomplishments
the acquisitions
the reputation
ownership
which we begin to identify ourselves as
and to begin to recognize that Pierre
tell yard
the great French priest
who was excommunicated from the Catholic
church for his outrageous ideas in 1918.
um
he said you're not here as a human being
having a spiritual experience that it's
the other way around and you've all
heard it that we are all infinite
Spiritual Beings having a temporary
Human Experience
and beginning to live our life from this
spiritual place
its place of spirit where we recognize
and identify ourselves not on the basis
of what the ego says which is on the
basis of what we have and what we
accomplish
what we own
and what others think of us
not based on our belief in our
separation from each other
and most egregiously not based upon our
belief and our separation
from God
a shift if you will to an awareness of
of our own divinity
and from that place
what is possible for all of us
so I'm going to
recite a poem here
from a
a great poet his name was Samuel Taylor
Coleridge
he
he wrote a poem called the rhyme of the
Ancient Mariner
and he also wrote one that wasn't that
well known I put it in a book of mine
years ago called real magic
I started it with this and I'd like you
to as I give these words I I'd like you
to think about what the poet is asking
and whether or not you believe in your
heart or know in your heart that what
I'm what the poet is saying is possible
for you
or whether you think it's just the fancy
kind of uh fanciful uh
meanderings and dreamings of a
of an idealist
ask yourself does this possible
he said
what if you slept
and what if in your sleep
you dreamed
and what if in your dream
you went to heaven
and there
picked a strange and wonderful flower
and what if
when you awoke
you held that flower in your hand
ah what then
he concludes his poem ah what then
I wonder if you think such a thing is um
is really a possibility
that you can go into a state in which
there is no form
no Beginnings no ends No Boundaries
no limits
and bring from that invisible place
something that has
substance
that has boundaries that has formed that
you can hold that you can smell
and then ask yourself if that's a
possibility
I wonder how many of you think yes
and how many of you think no I I'm not
going to ask but um
the fact is that
this room has it looks like
2500 or so people in the room tonight
um
every single one of you
are an example of what that poet just
described
every single one of you came from a
formless place
and are now formed
all of you
every flower that you look at
began in a seed and the seed began
in something that is invisible
there's a little girl here tonight
Camille where's Camille
six years old or so seven years old I
was
I was swimming with her a little while
ago and she showed me her teeth
she said I lost two of my teeth
and look there's two two teeth coming
underneath it and she was all excited
about that
and um
I said to her mom and my daughter summer
who was here
um just imagine
that in that tiny little infinite
infinitesimally small little speck
that built into that
was what she's going through right now
what is there to do
there's nothing for us to we can we
can't make a change
in that tiny little invisible Speck
everything that you needed for this
physical Journey was handed for you
and you don't believe in miracles
[Music]
and the great Dao many of you know I
lived the Dow for a year the year I
turned 65 and wrote a book on it
a book that I always tell people carry
it with you wherever you go
some call it the wisest book ever
written
and
I lived the principles of that little
book
and I encourage people to
to just stick it in your
new purse
the ones that are made out of plastic
recycled
water bottles is that all right
and um
but just carry it with you because you
don't even really need to uh open it
because the energy from what's in here
will come to you
I had a great teacher in India used to
say he wrote a
a a collection of his writings was
called I Am That by uh Nissan
he used to say to his devotees you don't
have to read it just carry it with you
and
I heard that I was in my early 40s
when I heard that and I just thought
this is just another one of those crazy
guys over there in India giving us
advice and I just didn't think that it
would be possible to get
but now I've
really come to an awareness that energy
is in everything
and that um just holding this book
literally you could you could muscle
test this kinesiology
and put this thing next to your heart
and you will be stronger with it than
you were without it just try it
just carry it with you
let me see who would like a copy of this
oh that hand right there the first hand
up there you yep no next to you yeah
stand up
would you like to carry this with you
wherever you go there you are God bless
you the Dow the ching
it's only a few dollars
it's worth having one of the great lines
in the Dow is what I'm speaking about
here at these opening lines is that um
it says that none of you are doing
anything
you're all just being done
[Music]
and when you look at your physical body
there's a recognition that this is
absolutely true you know
and what can you do to change it you
know things are drooping folks
you can fix them up if you want to but
the inevitable is there and the hair
well for some of you it turns gray and
for some of you it just turns it just
goes somewhere else
and you begin to
see there's also a great line in the
book because my son who's sitting in the
front row
Sands who graduates in a couple of weeks
and it's going to start supporting me
I'm so happy about that
um because I often have quoted Lao 2 and
he has often said
the Dao God Divine mind the Dow does
nothing
and it leaves nothing undone it's all
perfect
so I say to him over the summer over in
my way I said Sans come on do something
you got to do it let's go we got to do
something he looked up and he said
I do nothing
and I leave nothing undone
so this stuff can come back at you it's
his favorite line now Taoist philosopher
so the great Saint uh Swami muktananda
was asked the question what is real
and his response is really worth you
hearing
and something for you to really think
about because the strange place that I
think it's weird it's just
um
it's just so magical but it's still it's
just it's hard for us to wrap our arms
around this idea that all things are
possible
this this
awareness that um
that about what is real and muktananda
said that is real
which never changes
so what part of your
physical life
meets that definition
[Music]
we are all
in
these bodies that are changing every
second
therefore by that definition they're not
real so you go back and um
look at how many bodies you've been in
since you showed up here
you were in a body about this big that
weighed somewhere between five and ten
pounds
and that was you
and you were in a little toddler body
about this tall and
she certainly if someone said is that
you you would have said yeah that's me
and then you were in a 13-year 12 year
old body
which is one of these I have six
daughters
and they have a stance you know and
they're about 13 and they go like this
and their leg goes up and down and they
roll the rise and look at you like
you ought to try to get a life someplace
you're in one of those bodies teenage
body and you thought that was real
that's when you get the great learnings
one of my daughters Serena said to me
one time when I raised my voice
and ask her to hurry up and get moving
come on
she looked at
I wonder what all those people would
think of Mr positive if they could see
him here this morning
she turned to her sister and said
would you buy a book from someone who
yells at his 11 year old daughter hi hi
sneak out of the room and try to
best line I ever heard from any of my
children ever and I follow them around
with a pad of paper
to give me material
was for my daughter summer
when she was 13 and her sister was 11.
sitting at the breakfast table and
all of a sudden about 6 30 in the
morning and
summer looked at Serena and said well
if you didn't have any feet would you
wear shoes
Serena at that time
and it hasn't gone away
um could hardly stand anybody talking to
her at six o'clock in the morning
and so that's the most ridiculous thing
I've ever heard you say don't even talk
to me why are you why are you just don't
even talk to me close your mouth why are
you talking to me that's so stupid what
if I didn't have any feet would I wear
shoes of course not
summer looks I said don't get mad at me
I just wonder why you're wearing that
bra that's uh
so
[Applause]
you were in one of those bodies
I was in a 20 year old body and I saw a
picture of it on the PBS show and I was
doing a little bit of this and the
pictures of me at various stages of my
life were going by and the film was uh
uh the camera was looking at this
picture and it stopped on a picture of
me when I was about 20 years old
and I'm 70 when I was 51 years ago
and um
there's not one cell
of that body left on this planet
I really thought it was real
and when you were in your 20 year old
body you thought it was real didn't you
I mean it's just like you'd look at it
of course it's real and now you look
back at it and say if it was real
where is it
and where did it go
Emily Dickinson another great poet one
of my very favorite poets from
Massachusetts would
um
would give talks back in the 19th
century and she would pick up a handful
of of dirt
she would say just let this in
this quiet dust
was gentlemen
and ladies
and Lads and girls
was laughter
and ability and sighing
and frocks and curls
this passive place
a summer's Nimble Mansion where Bloom
and bees fulfilled their Oriental
circuit then
ceased
like these
that's who you are if you believe that
you're your body
just quiet us that's going to fulfill
its circuit and cease
and we all know that we're something
much more than that
but we haven't been raised to believe
that
so
my talk tonight
is really about understanding
there is a
component of us
that is
beyond the physical meta
beyond the physical metaphysical
Beyond form trans over past higher than
form transformed
and this um
this part of Who We Are
has infinite possibilities
and can do anything
can heal anything
can manifest anything
can attract into our lives the right
people
and you get a sense after a while that
um
that this invisibleness that is Who We
Are
is as you begin to elevate your
awareness and move to a higher level and
and this is basically the essence of it
it's that
we were all
conceived and born into a world and a
culture
in which
we were raised to be ordinary
an ordinary isn't so bad I'm not here to
put down ordinary and average and
fitting in and all the things that
ordinary comprises
it's just
not what I want for me
and I got the mic tonight
so
an ordinary really means um it means
fitting in
it means getting along
it means becoming a good citizen
it means filling out the forms
it means paying your taxes it means
having your children and providing for
them and taking care of them and going
to work going to school and getting good
grades and graduating and
your family and doing all of this
all of this these ordinary things
and then getting to the uh
later stages in your life where you
become a grandparent and then you live
your life
through your grandchildren
and then you die
and
and this isn't an indictment of that
it's um it's for me an awareness that if
I put my hands here about at my waist I
am speaking about ordinary consciousness
and
where I would like to take you tonight
where I have been taken in my life
particularly in the last year or so and
particularly in the last decade or so
um is to a place that I call
extraordinary awareness
an extraordinary awareness
is um
it encompasses all of ordinary
so that you're listening to an ordinary
man
I fill out the forms or I get somebody
to do it for me
more like it
um and I pay my taxes and I've provided
for all of my children
the
when I went to school and saw that they
went to school and
was there for them
as much as I could be and
did all of the things that we would say
constitute ordinary
but extraordinary doesn't doesn't stop
here
see this is where it stops for so many
people
and they go through their life with this
um remember the Barbra Streisand song is
that all there is
the sense that that there's more
there's a calling there's something in
me that is transcends the physical that
transcends ordinary and this something
that um
wants to move us to this extraordinary
level out here is um is beyond the ego
everything I've spoken about here is is
the ego
it's the striving for
it's um
okay
it's it's an identification and a belief
in my identity
as a physical being and believing in
what my physical self tells me is my
reality
and evaluating it on the basis of what I
can see and touch and feel and smell and
hear so that it's my senses my my
sensory self is here
but this up here
between ordinary and extraordinary where
I believe anyone can go at any time
here we are what EE Cummings another
favorite poet
he said to be nobody but yourself
in a world
which is doing its best night and day
to make you just like everybody else
means to fight the greatest battle there
is to fight and never stop fighting this
is how the poets think it's about going
Beyond average it's about going Beyond
ordinary
it's about recognizing your own divinity
it's about understanding that there's
something inside of you that is calling
you
it's your spirit it's your soul
and your soul your spirit is here in the
distance between here and here
and your soul wants something very very
different than your physical body ego
apparatus wants
it it's really it's not interested in
fitting in
it doesn't care whether you're right it
doesn't care whether people like you it
doesn't care about whether you're a good
citizen or not
I wrote these words out the other night
let me share them with you
it says I said
the ideal because I'm going to write
about this
the ideal of the Soul
the thing that it asks for
is neither knowledge
nor light nor happiness
the ideal of the Soul
is space
the ideal of the soul is immensity
the one thing it needs is to be free to
expand
to reach out
to embrace the infinite
yeah the ideal of the soul is infinity
it is
it is miserable
when it is circumscribed and restricted
the soul
is not
finite
what is finite
finite means it has a beginning and it
has an end doesn't it so it's that's it
it stops here and it's finite
the opposite of finite is infinite
infinite
and what is infinite what does it mean
when something is infinite
it means that it is always expanding
right it doesn't stop anyplace
it is always growing it's like the
universe it's just infinite what do you
think is at the end of the universe
just try to imagine a finite universe
and we come up with well what would be
at the end of it
and what we think is at the end of it is
what what is there a wall
yeah
if there's a wall at the end of the
universe
the poet would ask
what's on the other side
and where does that end
so this getting in touch with this
infinite part of ourselves
is really the part of us that says there
was a song that was popular when my
mother was a young woman
it was called Don't Fence Me In
I'll give Milan lots of land and the
starry skies above
Don't Fence Me In remember that song all
the old folks singing
just looking at me what is he gonna do
now he's going to embarrass me
we don't want to be fenced in now before
I had any children
I had eight theories about how to raise
children
I even wrote about them
now we have eight children
I have no theories
[Music]
but the one thing I know
about raising children
is this
that nobody likes being told what to do
right Sage
I was telling the story of uh you honey
um on Mother's Day
one year at a restaurant where we're all
there and my mother Marcy's mom and dad
and we're all there and
and um Sage is um
in a lot of ways like me the the what I
call the I tell the story at every talks
I might as well hear it's a the scurvy
elephant
when I was in the foster home back in
Mount Clemens when I was about six or
seven years old I came home from school
and Mrs scarf who ran this home had this
home that a bunch of us lived and I came
home and I asked her what's a scurvy
elephant
and she said a what and she said a
scurvy elephant I mean I said and she
said well where did you hear that I said
well I heard Mrs Poole who was my third
grade teacher talking to the principal
and she said that Wayne Dyer was in her
classroom and that he was a scurvy
elephant
so she got on the phone called the
principal and the principal said oh no
she said that's Wayne he gets everything
mixed up
she didn't say that he was a scurvy
elephant in her classroom
she said that he was a disturbing
element
in her classroom
and I always love to say that
so
a scurvy elephant is and my teacher
Abraham Maslow who does always say to us
um
you know the the number one marker of
self-actualizing people is their their
independence of the good opinion of
other people they're just not interested
in being told what to do I watched on
the
um
on my
iPad
which I just got
um
and it um
it had a
commencement address by Steve Jobs
at Stanford University
it was a 15 minute and I just sat there
and before I meditated I
listened to what he had to say this
immensely scurvy elephant who really I
mean just passed away a few weeks ago
and
um you know many his biographer is now
saying that he's up there with Thomas
Edison and Benjamin Franklin and
Alexander gray and Bell people like that
I mean he really changed who we are as a
people and how we communicate with each
other and his advice to the whole
graduating class at Stanford was don't
live somebody else's Dharma
don't listen to that inner calling and
whatever it calls you to do listen to it
and don't pay attention to anybody
telling you what's possible or what's
not possible or just
fight for it
Sage was at Mother's Day and I don't
even remember what it was that she
wanted to wear or didn't want to wear
but um it had something to do with
dresses and skirts and slacks and
I remember that Mother's Day
walking in the parking lot
with sage
for 45 minutes or so talking to her
about I know exactly how you feel and
how you think I said but there's a lot
of people who think that you should
maybe wear something nice it's Mother's
Day and it's a restaurant I said but you
don't have to go back in there we'll go
home and get something afterwards if you
want and uh
she just give me that I don't want to do
this and why should I be told what to
wear and
I understood that
I understood it very strong and she's
still doing that
hmm
but it also serves people very very well
this idea that um I'm going to listen to
that voice and we all have it and when
we have this voice and this voice has
passion
associated with it
that is when you feel a strong passion
towards what it is that you want to
become what you want to create the kind
of person that you intend to to be when
you have that within you
um
it doesn't make any difference whether
anybody else understands it or gets
along with it you don't even try to talk
to anybody else about it you just listen
to it and you become a disturbing
element you become a scurvy elephant
in the world
and
and it's the only way you'll ever feel
fulfilled
you won't get it by
by fitting in so in order to
you have to listen to your soul
and your soul is that invisibleness
and your soul is not finite
therefore everything up to here
is finite everything that I spoke about
filling out the forms fitting in being a
good citizen doing all the right things
all these things which I applaud which
are all fine but they only take you
[Music]
um
you end up living a half-lived life
Herman Melville
I spoke about him this morning when I
spoke to the writers group here
I mean his writing was so profound and
so beautiful and he uh he had this one
line from Moby Dick
which is really not the story about a
man chasing a whale
it's the story of um
a person who has an obsession
and that whale is a symbol of I must
achieve it
I've had a really great book this summer
every one of my kids have read it it's
called Unbroken
by Lauren hillebrand
and um I recommend that you read it and
wherever this is going around the world
get a copy of it it's the story of Louis
Zamperini who
survived
on a raft across the ocean and was taken
to a Japanese prisoner of war camp and
on and on and on and survived Against
All Odds
and then at the end was able to go back
and forgive I mean it's just a powerful
beautiful spiritual experience and
and Ahab was uh
was pursuing his own inner voice that
just couldn't be stilled
and this is how Melville spoke because I
live on an island
in the middle of the Pacific
Maui where I invite you to come in
January to listen to the whales
go on a whale watch with me and if you
like what I'm speaking about here
tonight we do three to two or three days
on it in January
here's Melville
he said for as this
a public ocean
surrounds The Verdant land
so in the soul of man
lies one
insular Tahiti
full of peace
and joy
but encompassed by all of the Horrors
of the half-lived life
the half-lived life is the life that
gets you to ordinary
filling out the forms and then stopping
the self-actualized life
starts at ordinary
and
listens to its soul
which you can't find
but you know is there
and there are some that doubt that it's
there I had a friend who's a
neurosurgeon over in Maui and he was
saying you know you talk about this Soul
Thing a lot he said I've poked around in
a lot of human brains and I've never
seen a soul or anything resembling a
soul
and I asked him I said Chuck I said um
while you're in there poking around
have you ever seen a thought
well no of course not I said
do you think there are thoughts
that such a thing as a thought exists
you can't see it you can't touch it
again
the fact is that virtually everything
that exists is
metaphysical beyond the physical
it's very limited our physical world and
it's not even real
by muktananda standards because it's
always changing
the body that you came into this room
with will be a different you'll leave in
a different body there's something
called you
that just keeps occupying
more and more and more new bodies
until ultimately it just sheds it all
together
the great Irish poet William Butler
Yates said
an aged man
is but a paltry thing
a tattered coat upon a stick
what an image
unless
Soul claps its hands and sings and
louder sings
for every tatter
in its mortal dressed
we're just tattered coats on a stick
unless we have a soul
and when we have a soul
the soul says
Don't Fence Me In
the soul says don't tell me what to be
don't tell me what I can't do
don't you dare impose upon me
who you are and what you think I should
be that's your soul
and all of you have this
because this body of yours
is Just an Illusion
it's just a very temporary parentheses
in eternity isn't it
and you know that you're going to leave
it
and all the evidence is there and you
just keep looking at it you try to
pretend that it's not there and
so you color the gray the color of the
gray and you lift them up and you shift
it around and you put on a girdle and
you do all of that I don't know you do
all of the stuff to pretend that it and
you're not doing a damn thing in this
world you're just being done
you're just being done
but what you're being done by
is the higher self
so
what I would like to offer you here
is a
a program if you will a sort of a
preview I've been reading and studying
and um
lecturing all over the place
for the last year or two
and
for some reason I've been given a a big
voice and a
a big audience
for some reason I'm I'm allowed to go on
public television and and present in
Prime Time three and four hour specials
on the Dao de ching
or on
the power of intention
or unchanging your life
living from a spiritual place and um it
must be because I have had this um
wonderful opportunity handed to me
that um I've been getting exposed to
more and more and more but about
um
the miraculous power that comes to us
when we
start our life from ordinary
and just leave that part of it to be
taken care of and move into this
extraordinary place
this place um
that all the great writers speak about
where we where we transcend this ego
this ego of ours that's um
believes that who we are is so important
and believes that who we are is what we
own
and who believes that what we are is in
competition with others and has to
defeat others
and has to win and has to
has to be better than
I love The Poets I feel very poetic
tonight a great
um
Indian poet
named rabindranath tagore
when the Nobel Prize for literature in
1927 with a collection of poetry called
gitanjali
and in there he writes about this ego of
ours
he says um
I went out alone
on my way to my tryst
but who is this me
in the dark
I step aside to avoid his presence but I
escape him not
he makes the dust rise from the earth
with his Swagger
he adds his loud voice to every word I
utter
he is my own little self my Lord
he knows no shame
but I
the invisible me I am ashamed
to come to thy door
in his company
that's the ego
the part of us that makes the dust rise
from the earth with our Swagger
who's always adding his loud voice
but inside there's this being that says
who I am is so much more than that so
much more divine
and in order to get to the path of
moving towards extraordinary and the
fact is that um
even though many people will attend to
talk like this and many people will buy
the books and and study it and look at
it
the percentage of people who are willing
to leave ordinary behind
is very very small honestly it's only a
handful of people in this room even
though the intentions are good
the um
the book that I'm reading now I came
across a quote
um
I think I'm going to read it
if I have it here ah here it is it was
by a a French
philosopher mathematician some of you
studied him when you took a philosophy
class his name was Renee Descartes
he's the one who said I think
therefore I am
I don't like to question these guys I
used to teach them at the University but
I think he had it backwards
I really believe it should be I am
therefore I think
well that's just my opinion I'll talk
about it later and Descartes said in
order to reach the truth
it is necessary at some point in one's
life to rid oneself of all the opinions
one has ever received
and to rebuild one's entire system of
Knowledge from the very Foundation
and I think I've done that recently just
tossed out I think this diagnosis of
leukemia two years ago really helped me
to do that
and to just say I'm starting over
I'm going I'm going here
and
I've been doing it in some ways many of
people think I've done it my whole life
but honestly I haven't I've walled
around in that ego a lot in my life
and
and
so
in order to do this thing you have to
recognize that in a fundamentally
involves changing your concept of
yourself
and changing your concept of yourself
really means understanding what is your
concept of yourself like who are you
what is your concept of yourself
your concept of yourself
is everything that you believe to be
true
about yourself and what's possible for
you and anyone else
and it really means changing
most of that
because you have been raised to be
ordinary you've been raised to believe
in your limits and how far you can go
and you've been have this imposed upon
you by your well-meaning parents and
grandparents and culture and religion
and business and education the systems
that you have been IMM immersed into
have basically told you
get here
this is not for you
and it might not have even been done and
sometimes they might have even said oh
you can do anything
and then we'll start to tell you all of
the reasons all of the exceptions to
that
I'm imposing on you like
you gotta get dressed in a certain way
for Mother's Day and you've got to
fit in and you've got to do that's in
you and it's like
by God it's um
it's like the soul has
no finiteness to it
it it's infinite so it means it just
wants to keep expanding
it wants to keep growing because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for the
five lessons in life that people learn
too late check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there look for the job that you would
take if you didn't need a job I mean you
know don't sleep walk through life and
don't don't say it's all going to be
great you know I'll do this and I'll do
that and you know I'm just marking time
I'm going to be able